well this is gonna be like absolutely insane
if you guys do not know what is going on
just sit back and relax as it's going to blow
all of your minds as it did when i first read
the story like this story here is something that
is extremely special to me i first started reading
it at probably you know like the worst point in my
short life that i've had sob story i know like who
actually cares but there was a hitman involved so
it was an extreme level that most people probably
don't deal with anyways you know enough of
that i didn't know what i wanted to do like
kind of at this point but if it wasn't for the
utter enjoyment and pure love that i felt while
reading this arc literally everything wouldn't
have turned out how it has so for me being able
to share this arc with you is really special and i
wouldn't have dreamed a few years ago that i would
have been able to share one of the greatest arcs
and modern manga with you all and like i'm being
full on serious when i say this is like one of the
greatest arcs in modern manga this is on par with
like the international assassins arc from chainsaw
man and like it's better than a lot of the arcs
that i've ever watched so i don't really know
what to compare it to it's that freaking good so
i can't wait until hopefully this next season that
we get to see them but anyway firstly previously
on giga akatami's acid trip visualized we had the
chosen one himself satoru gojo fall into a deep
sleep in which we were shown through his dreams
probably one of the most damn high backstories of
the recent era side note though straight up gige
never misses with these arcs like i don't know how
he does it but it's just goddamn beautiful other
mangakas out there spam and training arcs like mha
but giga dropping hate always anyways anyways
gojo was able to overcome the powerhouse himself
toji for shigeru and his second match up however
we did lose the star plasma vessel which has some
extremely important effects that are going to
affect the modern day throughout the later parts
of this arc here but you know rico would have
actually been able to survive this incident if she
was just using her ultimate defense surfshark vpn
and well you guys know what surf shark vpn does
it secures your online activity and can protect
you from hackers data theft and secure your online
identity now honestly up until recently i thought
i'd be the last person to use a vpn as i can
always kind of find the shows that i'm looking for
on specific websites if you know what i mean but
after the new zealand border walls dropped and i
escaped the country with all my manga in hand for
the first time i soon realized that those same
websites can't even be accessed from different
places abroad i was left utterly confused and in a
catatonic state unable to move or think until they
arrived surfshark vpn and with a simple flick
of the wrist i was able to change my location
right back to my safe place where i know all the
websites i use work that wasn't even the end i was
so weeped up all of a sudden i started learning
formal japanese straight from the japanese
netflix page so that next time i get a strike
i can formally address them with my new cool
second language and you guys can too by easily
downloading surfsharkvpn from the link below or
by chucking in my beautiful code diavolo you get
83 off and three yes three months free on top of
it and it doesn't even stop there no matter where
you are whether it be in the house on the toilet
the fridge anything surfsharkvpn supports it all
so stop there stop watching go outside touch some
grass then come back in and download surfshot vpn
because if you don't who knows what might happen
to your unprotected device and especially your
family's devices couldn't be me man but anyway
thank you to surfsharkvpn for sponsoring this
video so continuing on october the 19th of 2018
gojo is asleep when megami yuji and nobara arrive
once awoken and after a small greeting gojo sends
them to udahime's location there she tells them
that there are two moles one of which is actually
one of the jujutsu higher-ups since they can't do
anything about that presently their main target is
whoever is feeding information to that said higher
up nobara asks if the mole is someone from kyoto
surprising yuji as utahime prepares to reveal
to them who it is elsewhere kasumi meets with
mikamaru she tells him that their notebooks are
due today and he replies that he is going to sleep
back at mikamaru's alleged hideout udahime informs
the tokyo first years that it has to be kokichi
due to the process of elimination using puppet
manipulation to steal information wouldn't be
difficult for someone like megamaru at the same
time kikichi prepares for his visitors however
yuji bursts down the door to the fake hideout
confirming to them that he's the mole at his
actual hideout kokichi meets with mojito and
ghetto okay you know quick note waves so i'm going
to call suede ghetto or sudokito however you like
to say it just ghetto from now on so it doesn't
get confusing but just know it ain't actually
ghetto so it's easier for me to call them just
ghetto until i can have that fair reveal on all
of you anyway anyway kokichi comments about how
he had thought that they had forgotten about him
but getty replies that they would never do that
since kikichi knows the consequences of having
a curse restriction asmojito suggests that they
kill kakichi since they have all the information
they need ghetto tells him that they have to heal
kakichi first before they can kill him due
to the terms of the binding vow between them
mojito begrudgingly uses his idol transfiguration
to heal kakichi giving him a healthy body for the
first time mohito remarks that kikichi should show
some enthusiasm but he replies that that comes
after they settle their business with no more
words left to be said the battle at the dam begins
kikichi calls an entire army of mikamaru's to
his side as his confrontation with ghetto and
mojito escalates he enlarges his arm and smashes
the wave of mikamaru's aside kokichi disappears
in the confusion and mojito figures that he run
away without any reason to kill them bored mojito
claims he's not in the mood for hunting suddenly
the underground leg collapses forcing mojito to
quickly escape outdoors mohito looks at the giant
lake with an excited smile as ultimate mikamaru
mode absolute appears from within its head doing
final checkups kikichi notices a curtain forming
around the area casted by ghetto he thinks that
he needs to escape the curtain and reach gojo
to let him know about shibuya however the only
way to do that would be defeating mojito first
knowing that he won't stand much of a chance
he still doesn't plan on holding back and
will use all 17 years five minutes and six days
worth of cursed energy he's accumulated to win
he starts off by sending an entire year's
worth of cursed energy into his ultimate
mikamaru and blasts mojito with his ultra cannon
destroying the dam and sending rubble flying
having dodged the initial blow mohito knows these
types of attacks won't be effective and dives into
the water using a two-year charge of cursed energy
kikichi blasts the entire lake with miracle cannon
but despite his best effort maheso leaps from the
water to radius strike at him kikichi believes
mojito was overlooking his offense so now it's
time to put his secret plan into action mojito
extends his arm and grabs on to mikamar's head
to accurately deliver a cursed energy infused
punch which vigorously shakes the cockpit inside
kikichi inserts a small tube into one of his side
panels and activates a curse technique charge the
tip of mikamaru's finger splits open to reveal a
small cannon which then instantly fires a spiked
projectile that stabs into mojito as he's flying
around initially mojito doesn't see it as a threat
but suddenly his wing explodes leaving him open
to get smacked aside by mikamaru mahato crashes
through several trees confused as to how his soul
was destroyed nikimaru then absolutely pummels
the ground forcing haito to fly away and retreat
kikichi notices mahito reshaping himself to hide
his injuries making him feel more confident that
he might win even ghetto acknowledges that kikichi
is skilled and his strategies are working against
mojito kikichi then uses an insane five-year
charge called pigeon viola to send five cannons
of cursed energy shooting at his opponents mojito
shape-shifts and tries to avoid the beams but he's
taken by surprise when mika mario crushes them
from above the curse narrowly avoids getting hit
but mikumaro follows up with another strike that
seems maheso flying back into the trees again
confident that he'll be able to achieve his dreams
kikichi activates another cursed technique charge
reshaping mkhimaru's middle finger into a
spike however the big bad wolf activates
his domain expansion the self-embodiment of
perfection which is just like hell acclaim
and i honestly love the growth of mojito's
character throughout the story dude thinks
he's like perfection but he's the absolute like
opposite of everything he thinks it's so good
idol transfiguration automatically hits and forces
ultimate mikamaru to collapse appearing to signal
kokichi's demise confident in his automatic
win strategy mojito turns his back to the giant
cursed corpse and states kikichi shouldn't put
so much faith into a strategy suddenly mikamaru
gets back up and stabs the spike on his middle
finger through mojito's back it is explained that
the cursed technique tubes contain simple domains
the domain for the weak invented in the heian era
out of the four tubes that contained it the first
failed the second protected the cockpit from the
domain and the third appears to have finished
mojito off for good as his body seemingly explodes
after being stabbed mikamaru roars and turns his
weapon towards ghetto ready to use his remaining
nine years to finish him off however the cockpit
abruptly explodes from the impact of mojito's
enlarged fist horrified kikichi looks through
the broken window to see mojito's deranged smile
kikichi takes his last technique tube and
desperately rushes towards mojito and little team
to stab him yet just as the two are about to touch
and skips away to kikichi recalling talking with
kasumi about getting to know one another better
she made a promise to come see him but sadly
mojito is ensured that that will never happen
mikamaru collapses for good with its pilot's
blood dripping from the titan's head recent peace
mikamara obviously big giga loves this character
and he like literally wears the disguise in public
so i wonder if perhaps he found kakichi to be an
extremely human character who to everyone else
seemed bad but you know us readers we realized
there was an entire level to his thoughts that no
one else had even considered from the beginning
anyways after leaving ghetto suggests to mojito
that perhaps he was cutting it a little too close
but mojito believes that it was all according
to plan ten days later we arrive at the moment
you have all been waiting for to what is the
absolute criminally crop of hands like oh my god i
can't even right now nothing and jjk even compares
so far to the absolute brutality that happens next
so yes finally on october the 31st 2018 the record
of shibuya incident begins at 7 pm when a curtain
is cast with a 400 meter radius in the middle
of shibuya city the rules of this person are
that non-sorceress can enter the curtain but
they cannot exit trapping themselves inside juju
sorcerers and managers can move through it as
they please but the reception is blocked so all
communication has to be maintained outside of the
curtain over with our favorite manager kiyotaka
ijichi he informs an army team of the situation
outside the curtain in the shibuya station
nanami expresses that the situation is quite a
pain while eno tries to inform megami about the
curtain obviously megami already knows like what
occurred and everything is so he just completely
ignores him and nanami ends up asking ajichi
where gojo currently is but meanwhile just
outside of the shibuya city business center nobody
has found where the normally busy intersection is
something terrible must have happened and everyone
would have spread out to probably the edges of the
curtains they're all asking the exact same thing
bring satoru gojo akari another manager from jiu
jitsu tech relays this information to the zenin
team the old dog naobiso understands that the
non-sorceress were told to say it sorcerers
are free to move in and out of the curtain
so that makes it impossible for them to break
the barrier with brute force the ideal strategy
is to look for and neutralize the curse user who
cast the curtain however each team is on standby
for now because the higher-ups decided that gojo
should work alone to suppress the shibuya incident
as quickly as possible inside the curtain the
civilians dressed in their halloween costumes or
discussed the situation at 8 31 pm saturday gojo
arrives inside of the curtain and makes his way
inside of the hikari shin kyu's shibuya shopping
mall he analyzes the situation and heads straight
down to basement floor 5 the lowest level
basement where the subway trains operate
at aoyama cemetery the meimei team awaits further
instructions yuji is eager to help and may may
surmises they'll be called in as back up shortly
wee-wee meimei's freaking weird younger brother
feels that she shouldn't be used in such a way
okay one sec i just need to cut myself off here
like i get it bro your sister is absolutely
banging and stuff but it doesn't mean you need
to go like all incesty bit well anyway they
then get a message that another curtain has
appeared along with gojo's arrival because of this
meimei's team turns and runs towards meiji station
back with my dad satoru he descends into the
tokyo metro onto a specific platform of failed
to pronounce probably way too many damn times
to even bother trying to say again where he's
confronted by chogo hanami and cho so satoru tells
joko to not have an excuse for losing this time
and joker replies that the strongest sorcerer
should have his first ever excuse ready sick burn
joker choker hitting him with a freaking sick burn
hanami's roots block all possible exits but gojo
claims he wasn't going anywhere anyway everyone
standing on the outside lanes of the platform is
suddenly forced onto the tracks surrounding
the fortuitously used with non-sorcerers
saturno nonchalantly tells those around him to
stand out of his way if they don't want to die he
realizes that blocking the exits created a blind
spot so he can't break through just in case there
are people on the other side heading for gojo jogo
burns through several civilians and chosen attacks
with slicing exorcism both hinami and jogo attack
saturday but are instantly stopped by his infinity
they strengthen their cursed energy and activate
domain amplification forcing saturday to dodge he
surmises that they learn this technique from a
curse user as normal barriers are meant to trap
their targets in a box but domain amplification
metaphorically surrounds the target with water
like curse energy with this method the curses can
neutralize the infinity for those who are like
obviously still confused i just think of kalua and
his like quick as [__] reflexes when he trains
the uh like during that dark game to get his like
reflexes up with the electricity and shooting like
grab it as soon as things hit the skin that's just
kind of like what i think domain amplification's
like in my head but i'm probably utterly wrong i
don't know someone let me know down below prior
to the shibuya incident ghetto advises his allies
that gojo is best when he's working alone any juju
sorcerers and non-sorceress will only restrict
his movements and render him incapable of using
his curse techniques in this situation satoru
would be forced on the defensive and even his
domain expansion would harm people so he explains
that the plan is to mess around and force gojo
to think of counter-measures for a period of time
until the prison realm is ready back in the battle
djogo snatches somebody's head off and reminds
saturday the rules were for him to not run away
saturday admits he was surprised and joker was
pleased to hear a possible excuse however gojo
rejects this and removes his blindfold revealing
his six eyes then adding that he's only surprised
because these foolish curses believed they could
use their brain to defeat him looking at hanami
he points him out and says that this is their
third meeting and their weed is getting cut first
without fear saturday walks right up to jogo
while ignoring hanami beside him they both move to
attack but saturday counts as jogo's hand with his
own body he avoids an army strike and snaps jogo's
arm clean off then uses it to block konami's
follow-up attack and continues to chase after jogo
hanami realises sasudu only made the threat
earlier to confuse them and not only that he also
deactivated his limitless technique he questions
if gojo plans to abandon focusing on his technique
and fight in close quarters instead because of
this hanami decides it's best to deactivate his
amplification and activate his innate technique
however this turns out to be a fatal mistake as
jojo turns back to yell at hinami sato instantly
grabs the tree branches growing out of the
hanami's eye sockets then forcibly pulls them
out completely from his skull saying this jogo
runs away in fear shocked that satoru was still so
strong while only using cursed energy manipulation
and physical attacks chozo attempts to hit gojo
with blood manipulation while killing civilians
along the way but it's stopped by gojo's infinity
satsuru recognises that chozo is a death painting
and decides to ignore him for now jogo and hanami
both attack him again with domain amplification
however this time due to the now weakened hinami
satoru can counter by strengthening his infinity
he turns and crushes an army against a wall with
his expanded limitless jogo attempts to divert his
attention by threatening civilians but satoru
doesn't hesitate to crush an army completely
annihilating the curse with his infinity turning
them into nothing but a mist of blood with an army
exercised gojo turns back to meet the despair
joko's gaze and claims he's next skipping away
from the absolute domination god is laying down
in shibuya right now we find ourselves with yuji
maymay and wee-wee as they arrive at meijiji
jingju may station and that is the last time i'm
ever saying the full name for that station where
they are informed that there are two barriers now
surrounding the station after being informed
about the situation meimei uses her ability on
some crows to investigate the immediate area when
she finishes scouting she informs yuji of what she
saw in the station yuji asks if mojito was down
there but meimei replies that she didn't see him
however he must be in there since there are
mutated humans literally all over the place maymay
then says that they will split up until they each
finish their respective tasks at 903 pm as usual
enters another entrance he comes across a random
bug cursed spirit who can talk and is obviously
somewhat strong yet this thing is just like so
damn relevant it doesn't even get a name well it
does it's like grasshopper or kogai but still you
try finding a name that isn't just grasshopper or
some japanese texts that translate to grasshopper
it's that's all that's out there i can't find
anything else yuji asks the spirit if mojito was
here twitch debug says that he is down below and
that he is currently protecting the barrier as
yuji wonders if the bug creature had put up his
screen he notices an object and realizes the
cursed spirit was only guarding the item that
projects the screen the grasshopper curse tells
yuji that transfigured humans don't taste as good
as normal ones and that he knows this because he's
smart annoyed yuji kicks the curse into the wall
he quickly follows up with a punch to the grass
of his torso and states that the curse needs to
stop looking down on humans the grasshopper says
that yuji isn't smart and those who aren't smart
die i actually hate this grasshopper man he
asks what kind of curse yuji thinks he is
and yuji is able to pick up on the obvious answer
this makes the grasshopper curse realise that yuji
is actually smart like actual pug brain man
dude deserves to be in a bug's life not jjk
you're making a lot of sense i mean why take
the risk you should tell hopper good idea yeah
that's good it's good lower lower hey a hop go
away that's fine then i won't tell you my idea
good the grasshopper curse lunges at yuji with
his jumping power and tries to chomp down on him
yuji avoids the attack while assessing its
strengths recognizing its ability to communicate
makes it a more powerful curse it gets behind
yuji and tries to punch him but yuji can talk
to his body and continues to avoid getting hurt
the dumbass grasshopper asks if yuji is smart
and his student reveals to it that smart people
don't generally ever brag about being smart this
genuinely shocks the grass of a curse who covers
his mouth from surprise like dude i i can't even
right now for like like being serious i can't be
serious with this dude they then engage in close
quarters and trade blows degrasso believes it
has the advantage in a numbers battle because it
has two more arms however yuji easily overpowers
and batters his opponent with far superior skill
the grasshopper curse attempts to shoot black
mucus at yuji but he ducks under and prepares to
deliver an uppercut however grasshoppers actually
have an expandable abdomen to lay eggs underground
and he uses this in an attempt to strike gucci
with the extended hard tip while he's low
yuji is fast enough and knocks the appendage aside
before separating it completely will they chop
he then exercises this stupid little grasshopper
before breaking the stake and undoing the curtain
meanwhile maymay kills the transferred humans on
the basement floor 4 and maymay decides that they
should stay and wait to regroup with yuji before
heading down to the fifth level below them mahido
prepares to board the train from harajuku to
shibuya station he notices that the grasshopper
curse was defeated and admits that it must have
taken a skilled sorcerer to do so mojito expresses
his disappointment having desired to fight as well
but knows what he must do and sticks to the plan
back in the beat down with our boy gojo
joko frantically huffs the air as he runs
stumbling through the crowded platform saturday
follows close behind him with an extremely dark
and menacing presence our brother choso lets joko
take all the heat while quietly trying to hide in
the chaos among the civilians joko tries to push
people in saturday's way and strike from behind
but the infinity is able to stop the person in
midair as well as jogo's punch chouso nonchalantly
shoots three blood arrows from a good distance
down the platform the infinity stops them and
saturn knows chosen's location but chooses to
ignore him again honestly thank gojo for real
he didn't just mur choso first thing like he knew
he knew something was going on behind the scenes
anyway still worrying joko believes that 20
minutes should have passed already down the line
though ghetto waits with the gone and states that
they need to get gojo on edge more before they
make a move meanwhile at meiji stations fourth
floor the maymay team regroups and heads down
one more floor on the way down mameka means yuji
and states his strengths yuji replies by revealing
that it wasn't mojito on the second floor
and it wouldn't have been that easy if it was
carrying his sister's battle axe where he sternly
tells yuji to graciously accept his sister's
compliment honestly this cuck of a kid needs to
just leave he's literally just a vehicle bro after
reaching the third floor they find a civilian but
his head immediately trans figures and he dies
before he died though he mentioned everyone was on
the train this makes yugi realize that it's headed
straight for where gojo is back at hikari shinku's
station satoru was surprised to see that the train
is arriving some of the civilians attempt to get
on and flee but it's already stuffed to the brim
with transfigured humans that start attacking
as soon as they are left loose saturn watches in
horror while mojito hops out of the train to greet
jo go civilians run away in fear as transfigured
humans rush from the train indiscriminately
attacking everyone inside saturday watches
in horror and doesn't believe whittling down the
numbers of humans as to his opponent's advantage
mohito tries attacking flying through the air
swiping at gocho but he easily blocks it he then
figures out quickly that mojito is the one that
attacked yuji and an army and tries to attack him
but mojito jumps back out of the way the creepy
boy then comments about how he finds humans so
disgusting since there are so many of them and
as he says this people begin pouring down into
their floor from above as gojo figures they're
the cursed spirits have allies who are above
sending more people to their location mojito uses
idol transfiguration multiplicity body repel and
choso in combination uses his blood manipulation
convergent supernova technique to attack a crowded
gojo however gojo easily blocks them killing a
bunch of civilians in the process from behind
joko appears launching at gojo the sorcerer
manages to grab his arm but yogurt instantly saves
the limb to get away mohito and joko think about
the current situation believing gocho won't use
his technique as he doesn't want to incur any more
civilian casualties yet obviously these negative
iq eggs are absolutely shocked when gojo goes goth
mode and activates his freaking domain expansion
saturday's all or nothing domain expansion of 0.2
seconds cast an unlimited void over the platform
the time was an educated guess that assumed
non-sorcerers could only stay within the domain
for that long without suffering permanent damage
in that time half a year's worth of info flooded
into everyone's brains immobilizing them at this
level these special great curses could awaken at
any moment taking that into consideration saturday
focuses on killing all of the transfigured humans
and in approximately 299 seconds one thousand
transfigured humans were annihilated after the
deactivation of the domain by the hands of
the strongest man alive immediately after
saturday notices a small box appear next to
him on the floor with the stage set for their
plan to succeed ghetto finally activates the
prison realm in a flashback before the battle
is explained that the prison realm is the final
remains of the buddhist monk genshin impact it
is a living barrier capable of stealing anything
even gojole joko inquires about the conditions
and kirta reveals that the target must stay
within a four meter radius for one minute
annoyed at the absurdity of this zogo threatens
him beginner was sure joko not to worry as his
version of one minute is slightly different in
the present ghetto orders the prison realm to open
the cursed object breaks out of its talisman
seal and expands into a cycloptic curse with
an eye in the center the eye meets saturday's
gaze and he instantly attempts to flee however
ghetto reveals himself and greets saturday as if
he had never even died in the first place confused
memories of his best friend rushed through
satoru's mind and he still can't understand
how ghitto could even be alive he's sure he killed
him himself but his eyes tell him something else
when ghetto said one minute to jogo in the past
he meant one minute worth of time that processed
within saturday's six eyes enhanced brain although
it was just a moment three years worth of memories
flooded in causing the prison realm to instantly
capture gojo immobilizing him and shutting off all
access to his body's cursed energy recognizing
that he is lost he still demands and know who
getto is as gojo knows in his heart that suguru
is dead and that this man is a fraud the man then
removes these stitches and takes off the top of
his head revealing the true villain of the entire
series i think and that he is indeed capable of
switching bodies along with using that said bodies
possessed natural abilities saturday was still
confident that yuta will step in in his place
however big brain ghetto argues yuta ikotsu cannot
become the next saturday gojo he bids farewell to
satoru and tells him he will release him into the
new world after his plan has succeeded so you know
he will come back eventually meanwhile down the
line team meimei heads towards saturday's position
suddenly yuji stops and as you asks what's up he
finds a small mikamaru like communication device
randomly on his ear asking if he can hear his
voice yuji is quick to take it off and attempts
to break it but kokichi quickly reveals that
sato gojo has been sealed back at the station
the imposter addresses gojo and mockingly bids him
good night to which gojo replies by saying that
it might be good night for him but for him it's
time to wake up and ghetto's arm suddenly moves up
grabbing his own neck ghetto is even stunned by
this and tells mojito his theory about their body
and soul being separate must be incorrect satoru
tells them to get this over with anger agrees
closing the gate and selling satoru gojo at last
meanwhile maymay doesn't believe kokichi but he
provides information around his own death saying
that he was killed by mojito on october the 19th
on october the 19th and that this puppet is
simply a contingency plan there are only three
of these puppets in separate locations and one was
given to meimei's team because they are the least
likely to be the actual moles kikichi warns them
that there is a curse user coming to attack them
saying that they are stronger than the
grasshopper and likely around semi-grade one
neime wants to ignore them and reach gojo but
kokichi advises them to focus on taking down the
four barriers that have appeared around shibuya
all the teams on standby there have likely been
caught inside a curtain and are unable to use cell
phones this goes for managers as well so kikichi
tells yuji to head back to meiji station and then
go over to shibuya above ground from there kikichi
asks meimei to defeat the curse user and clear
the path for yuji to what she agrees kihichi
understands the jujutsu world and human society
will be absolutely ruined if gojo disappears
so he asks them to put their lives on their line
to save him maymay notes that their enemies have
arrived and this ugly ass curse user abena appears
with his shikagami on a chain back at the hikari
building choso and jogo finally awakened from
the estate after the unlimited void suddenly the
prison realm drops to the ground out of ghetto's
hand cracking the floor inside satoru sits in an
unknown area surrounded by skeletons and notices
that time doesn't pass he admits he messed up but
believes everything will be fine because he has
faith in everyone else teams kusakabe zenin and
nanami all discuss the situation outside the
curtin team nanami agrees amongst themselves
that the most concerning new development is
the appearance of another curtain trapping
gojo and preventing sorceress from entering it's
already been almost an hour since gojo arrived in
shibuya so from their perspective it's difficult
to understand why the enemy would wait until now
nani decides to head for the curtains caster and
asks ino and megamike to do their best to rescue
civilians all three teams of jiu jitsu sorcerers
then head into shibuya at the same time outside
the perimeter of the curtain ajichi talks on the
phone with the other manager akari he asked her
to confirm the situation inside the curtain and
get back out as quickly as possible ajit plans to
get everyone off duty involved but before he can
do that he's suddenly stabbed from behind by the
freaking creep haruta shigemo pulls his sword from
ajijic's guts and watches him fall onto the ground
from behind a mysterious monk orders him to
continue targeting the people in suits around
the curtains perimeter then hit inside after
back in shibuya station big brain ghetto explains
that the prison run requires time to process gojo
before it can be moved mahito suddenly notices one
of mykomoro's communication devices on the roof
nearby and destroys it kokuchi immediately relays
the information about the enemy being unable to
move gojo to ug he says that it's best to move
in on the shibuya station from the surrounding
subways and once all the curtains preventing the
sorceress from reaching gojo are down they can
then take the station simultaneously yuji runs
into the curtain trapping civilians and using his
blinding speed and cursed energy he clears out the
group of transfigured humans to help rescue the
civilians yuji keeps up the momentum and then
climbs a large building with ease before yelling
out in an army yuji's scream echoes throughout
shibuya reaching an army team duty continues
yelling revealing that gojo sensei was sealed
team kusukabe hears this as well and a new shocks
nanami to the point he immediately changes plans
megami is also surprised to hear that his mentor
has been sealed and an army says that if it is
true then all humans in japan are surely doomed
ghetto gets mahito jogo dagon and choso into a
group and informs them of his next move he'll
remain here to protect the prison realm and asks
the cursed users on how they plan on dealing with
all of these sorcerers hitting their way chosu
simply wants to avenge his brothers by killing
yuji and obara to which jogo says that yuji is off
limit for being zukun's vessel but cho so simply
doesn't care mojito tells joko to calm down and
playfully reveals that he wants to kill yuji too
after seeing gojo in person mahiro is confident
that their side already holds a solid advantage
over the sorcerers and that they can win without
sakuna's help he expresses his unusually messed
up smirk and instead suggests that they all try
to kill yuji annoyed jogo asks if mojito is being
serious and he replies that he is for real jogo
knows that sakuna isn't the ally and could cause
them all to suffer but the error of curses will
still surely come regardless he believes curses do
not fear death and can walk their paths sincerely
to achieve their goals mahiro argues that even
if a cursed spirit is constant along that path
they still live according to their desires he
acknowledges that reviving sukuna is a legitimate
strategy but mojito doesn't want to fight jojo
over it instead mojito turns it into a game if he
encounters yuji first he'll kill him and if jogo
finds him first he can use the fingers to restore
sakuna's power chozo adds that if he finds yuji he
will try to kill him as well this annoys jogo but
mojito is excited to see that choso wants to play
too guido decides to pass on the game and stay
behind with the prison realm joko interrupts and
argues that it's the safest and smartest strategy
for them all to remain in place with ghetto and
wait for yuji and all the remaining sorcerers
to come to the m however mojito choso and even
dagon run off once the game starts determined
to not let them find yuji first jogo runs off
as well and inadvertently decides to take part
instantly after ghetto notices mimiko and nanako
watching him and says that the curses are smarter
than them they state that they helped with killing
monkeys and demand sugurugero's body back as
promised they don't want the imposter using their
beloved master's body any longer getter refuses
though and tells the girls that they should make
a binding vow whenever dealing with a sorcerer he
tells them to leave unless they want to be killed
by their master's body which is freaking insanely
brutal man they disappear into the crowd and
claim he'll live to regret this but the imposter
responds where they claim that it's been so long
that he's forgotten what regret even feels like
it's just a pretty badass thing to say meanwhile
yuji stands on top of a building in shibuya and
continues yelling for nanami after nanami's team
find him yuji and mikamaru bring them completely
up to speed as far as the situation revolving
around gojo nanami agrees coordinating an attack
from the adjacent stations makes sense for a
battle plan but in order for that to work they
must lift the curtain first the nami asks eno
to take the first years and lower the curtain
prohibiting the sorceress from entering the
station whereas he's going to hit outside the
curtain and meet up with the gichi additionally
nami wants eno to pass along any information to
the other teams if he encounters them after the
grade one source relieves aino debris megami and
yuji so they understand the severity of failure in
this situation if satoru gojo disappears the gojo
family falls out of power and anyone like yuji who
is being protected will be targeted by the jujutsu
higher-ups sorcerers and the community will fight
for political power and while they're doing that
all the curses and curse users that were held
back by gojo's presence will attack this means
if the juju high sorcerers fail here in shibuya
the age of humanity will surely be over in japan
meanwhile on top of the shibuya tower three
curse users watch over the commission curtains
they're excited to hear that gojo has been sealed
the old man wonders how this will affect japan
to which ogami replies that nothing will change
as cursed users will curse and the cursed will die
yuji tries to break through the curtain preventing
the sorceress from entering but the attack is
ineffective and the barrier doesn't even budge
eno is impressed with yuji's striking power but
this just means that the curtain is incredibly
sturdy as megami's divine dog totality kills
transfigured humans in the background to save
civilians he suggests that they try and find a
weak point in the curtain eno argues that there
is no weak point since they can't get inside
he believes that the curtains caster is within
the curtain but yuji explains how curtin's worked
at meiji station by staying outside the curtain
the risk of being seen increases and in return
the curtain strength does as well hearing this
megami surmises that the curtains projectors
are probably somewhere extremely obvious at
10 01 pm on top of shibuya tower giro or gyro
i don't know how to say his name exactly
awasaka looks down on the city and asks
if this is the most obvious spot to strengthen
the curtain ogami's grandson agrees but notes
that they will have to kill the curses
inside the building before getting to them
however they're both taken off guard when norway
suddenly appears flying above them as norway goes
in one direction yuji goes on the other then using
a wire he wraps up all of the curse users at once
ogami's grandson helps you get out of harm's way
but awakasa is swept clean off of the building
takuma takes his chance to break one of the
curse tools that is putting up the screen but
also realises that one of the enemies has taken
the other two curse tools with him preventing him
from continuing yuji further wraps up awasaka and
a wire and drags him downward at a faster velocity
yuji snaps the wire and dives inside the building
while yelling out for megami to deactivate norway
while dropping awasaka over 40 stories towards
the ground below back at the top of the tower
facing off with origami and her grandson eno
says that it's time for him to start paving
his way to becoming a grade one jiu jitsu
sorcerer and passionately lowers his mask
over his face back below megami flares up his
cursed energy and demands that the old man gets up
awasaka stops playing dead and smiles at his
opponents megami reminds yuji that they don't
have time to waste and he agrees on top of shibuya
tower cursed energy flows from aeno's body as he
activates his innate technique auspicious beast
summon eno possesses a science curse technique
that allows him to become a spiritual medium
by hiding his face in doing so he can summon
and use the abilities of four auspicious beasts
first eno summons kaichi and shoots a horn-like
projectile with homing missile capabilities at
the two however ogami's grandson puts his body
on the line to protect durr anu thinks that
he wants to rape up this fight as quickly as
possible and get back to the first years because
nanami entrusted him with looking after them
he tells himself to understand the effects and
control the self in order to eliminate one's
ego meanwhile yuji and migami fights alongside the
divine dog totality against awasaka the boys don't
find fighting the enemy difficult but working
together to be the hard part of this battle
they appear to be overwhelming the old man but he
remains completely unscathed despite all of the
efforts he slices at yuji with a knife but gets
caught in the toad's tongue and flung into the
bridge structure above him however he still isn't
hurt annoyed megami points out that they weren't
meant to be wasting time back at the top of the
tower ogami's grandson defends the old witch from
takuma's barrage of attacks while she continues
chanting behind him as ugami finishes her grandson
swallows something and starts to transform into
the literal civilian demon the destroyer of
freaking worlds daddy koji fushiguro though in
typical japanese manga cliffhanger style like i
can already see in this being the point in episode
ends on it skips away back to december the 7th
1989 the day saturday gojo was born in the past
cursed users were free and used their techniques
to kill others for money however that all changed
that day with his presence in the world the
balance of the jujutsu community was completely
altered the curse users were stripped of their
freedom and that feeling of dissatisfaction has
stuck with osaka and ogami ever since in the
present day osaka continues fighting with yuji
and megami he uses his lust for revenge on gojo
to fuel his anger in battle and beats back the two
first years this surprises these students as they
don't understand how he's nullifying all of their
damage megami figures out that it might be related
to his innate technique and decides to yell out a
boldfaced lie he says that gojo is in shibuya yuji
is confused but this helps megami confirm that
the cursed user's technique isn't something like
damage nullification they could counter gojo's
limitless technique awasaka claims that he's
ready to finish their battle and megami responds
by unleashing his new rabbit escape shikagami this
creates a wave of countless small rabbits that
are supposed to serve as a distraction however abu
saka has a random reaction to them as he's hit way
harder than he should have been this gets megami's
attention and he immediately tells yuji revealing
that he's figured out the enemy's curse technique
confused takumaino looks across the roof of
the shibuya tower at ogami and her grandson
who is shaped shifted into toshi for shiguro
and it figures out that the old woman is a
necromancer and he can tell with just one look
that toji is ridiculously strong the jiu jitsu
sorcerer attempts to summon his auspicious beast
ryu but toshi rips off his mask before eno even
knows what's happening he then lands a powerful
right hook on the sorcerer's jaw followed up by
grabbing anu's collar and pummeling his face with
a flurry of rapid fire punches down below awasaka
realizes the purpose of megami's rabbits is
more of a diversion than an actual attack
he wonders if the jews who hire students who tried
to hit him with a lethal blow from behind with the
rabbits when suddenly the curses are deactivated
and megami's max elephant falls from the sky with
him on top of its arwasaka manages to resist the
impact and the shukigami is deactivated just as
quickly as it appeared this annoys the old man who
demands megami to man up and fight him directly
megumi replies that that's more of his boy's style
and right on cue you he hears a freaking car at
osaka the cursed user is able to nullify the blow
though but it's still blown away by yuji's pure
strength me then gets awasaka's attention while
yuji prepares a full power swing awasaka believes
he can easily anticipate yuji's punch and megami's
attack at the same time as his curse technique
inverse makes strong attacks weak and weak attacks
strong he believes the harder his opponents fight
the easier he wins it is revealed though that
our boys had already figured out their opponent's
innate technique and megan me surmises that the
inverse technique must have a maximum and minimum
limit as the cursed user is reinforcing his body
with cursed energy on top of it understood and
suggested that they attack with a strong and weak
attack at the same time megami agrees stating that
they just need to keep the pressure on and prevent
him from realizing that they've figured it out
in the present exchange of blows yuji makes
contact and his punch is instantly nullified but a
simple poke from megami's toad's tongue is enough
to do serious damage awasaka pulls blood from his
mouth and before he even has a chance to recover
the guys resumed their beat down injured for the
first time in this battle awasaka refuses to lose
and forces the boys back demanding the kids don't
get cocky suddenly yuji gets behind the old man
and throws another powerful punch awasaka turns
around to counter it but yuji stops just before
he adjusts his strike throwing and now weaker
punch which awasaka's inverse makes extremely
powerful knocking him completely out impressed by
this megami tells yuji that he can pull off some
pretty dope ass moves with awasaki defeated yuji
and megami break the two commissioned curtains he
was holding deactivating the curd and preventing
sorceress from entering shibuya station as megami
thinks about interrogating the old man for some
answers eno is suddenly thrown from the top of
shibuya tower megami notices in time to summon
nue to rescue him from falling to his death yuji
catches eno and is horrified by the shape he's in
above them in toji foshigoro's form ogami's
grandson comments that the curtain is down
and asks what they should do now ogami asks him to
go down and keep killing sorcerers however toji's
personality tears its way through taking over the
body of the grandson and telling the old hag to
not give him orders worried ogami jumps back not
understanding how this happened is she only meant
to summon the body's information and not be soul
koji doesn't even know what's happening either but
he figures his heavenly restricted body overtook
the host's soul ogami doesn't believe this to
be possible yet to her dismay toshi decides to
follow her orders starting off by killing the old
hag first yuji wants to go back up the tower and
avenge eno but megami reveals that he's not dead
and asks yuji to focus on rescuing gojo while yuji
heads to the station megami agrees to take care
of eno the lesser doesn't like the idea of being
alone in shibuya but yuji is confident and having
mikamaru with him which is you know like pretty
funny when you think about it because the dude's
just the damn earpiece and like bro ain't helping
with any of the hands meanwhile the nami is left
horrified as he finds the jichi unconscious and
bleeding out at shibuya station at the same time
between the stations meimei easily overwhelms the
curse user abena in close combat with her battle
axe olkidio sits on top of abena's defeated curse
spirit as meimei explains how her innate technique
works maymay grew up believing her black bird
manipulation was a weak technique so she focused
on being effective without it ibina begs for her
forgiveness and asks to leave but wheyu tells
him to be quiet while his sister is speaking mama
explains that reinforcing one's body with cursed
energy can only take a sorcerer so far realizing
this meimei was initially devastated but the
realization allowed her to go back and master her
innate technique making meimei into the blossoming
grade one sorcerer she is today wee-wee weirdly
claps and makes abeena clap for his sister as well
mammy asks her brother why person's life value is
proportional to to what she says that life's value
is in proportion to how useful they are to may may
i love maymay bro but like i couldn't imagine how
cringed this would be like in real life since the
little kid say that [__] she then asks sabine
his server's potential and he's unable to answer
mamimy believes the fact that he can't answer as
a curse user and a murderer is the reason that he
lost she crushes his head with her axe and reveals
service potential as life itself for her wee
tells her sister that the curtain has been taken
down and mae mae gets excited at the prospect of
gojo owing her big time girl watches her movements
from the shibuya station and is impressed she
wants her quickly meanwhile on shoto bunkamaru
benkamura street i'm not saying that one again the
creep user shigimo encounters a rata and nobara in
the middle of the road nobara tells anita to stay
behind her and steps up to face the curse user
alone after slaying so many male managers shigemo
is excited to finally find some girls to play with
which if i remember correctly is like the exact
same thing he said at the end of the goodwill
arc the dude is just like a degenerate person
personified returning from taking ijichi to
safety nanami tells himself that he never has or
never will be frustrated by his own uselessness
he feels that he's just living in the face
of all of the evils in the world he thinks
about his fallen homies and mutters aloud how dare
they meanwhile this henan team fights against the
transfigured humans inside of shibuya akarinita
notifies them that it sounds like ejichi was
attacked while they were on the phone maki tells
nabarro and akari to go check on ajichi while
she stays with the old man while on the way nobara
and akari are confronted by the curse user shigemo
navarro believes that shigemo is the one who
attacked ijichi and she asks anita to pretend to
hide in the subway entrance while escaping through
to another shigemo interrupts the whisperings by
throwing her sword at nabara but she deflects
it with her hammer and charges at him confident
that he's a mid-range fighter suddenly shigemo
figures out that akari's not actually hiding
as akari runs through the station she passes
by shigemo's hand sword hanging off a wall
this leads shigemo right to her location where
he runs up to her and delivers a soccer styled
kick straight to the manager's chest upsetting
nobara and injuring akari navara tries to stop
him but the sword suddenly falls into shigemo's
hand allowing him to slash nabarro's leg leaving a
shallow card the cut distracts nobara's attention
allowing shigemo to attack her upper body with a
sword landing a fierce right hook to her jaw
completely dazing our girl nabarro loses her
balance and falls onto her knees she can't believe
how perfectly her opponent keeps landing shots she
even asks snowbarra if she's concussed nearly over
to talk to her in a taunting manner he claims that
she's gotten a lot stronger since they last met
but it doesn't matter in the face of his uncanny
curse technique namara tries to buy time by asking
shigemo about his motivations however he doesn't
have any convictions and kills simply because
it's fun for him he cuts akari while she's on
the ground angering nobara she tells him to stop
and he replies mockingly by asking her to make him
stop nibara stumbles back to her feet determined
to save akari and just as shigemo prepares to
finish her off they both detect an extremely
powerful presence nanami the big man himself walks
into the substation and immediately glares at the
curse user with a very less than happy expression
on his face shigemo notices nanami's attire and
wonders if he's supposed to kill non-black suits
too by the way like you are about to witness the
strength of a pure 9-5 working man while shigemo
wonders if he can kill non-black suits nabarro
recognizes nanami as the leader of megami's team
the cursed user tells the newcomer to read the
room as nanami wraps his necktie around his fist
and walks towards him shigemu tries to show
that he has he hostage but akari had called
up the escalator while he was distracted while
he expresses that he's sad that she got away
nanami appears directly behind him he asks jigimo
how many curse users there are and where they are
located shigemo turns around to quickly slash an
army and his shoulder claiming he doesn't know
he tries to follow up with a kick but
it feels like he's hitting a stone wall
nanami doesn't budge an inch and he's not
cut at all either surprising the assailant
and now he repeats his question asking where and
how many enemies there are shigemo is about to
claim that he doesn't know again but nanami uses
his ratio technique to create a weak point in the
opponent's body and back hands to mofo seen in him
flying across the entire room like dude actually
got dead handled so good shigemo bleeds profusely
from his face as his legs shake and he's barely
able to stand he believes he should have died and
credits his curse technique for saving his life
he wants to run but nanami grabs his hair and
repeats his question once again before shigemo
can even answer an army delivers a ferocious body
shot that slams shigemo into the wall behind him
shattering it upon impact with his life in very
imminent danger the curse user calls his curse to
rescue him it flies through the air in an attempt
to slash an army from behind but nobara nails it
to the wall shigemo tells her to stay out of it
but nanami interrupts and grabs him by the throat
instead of replacing the question again nanami
reveals he found several dead managers on his
way here he lifts his fist and charges it with
cursed energy asking if shigemo is responsible
terrified the helpless piece of trash apologizes
but it's too late as daddy hits him with his curse
technique smashing the boy's face leaving him
in an unconscious bloody heap nobara is amazed
by nanami's strength nothing that he is exactly
the model of what it means to be a true grade one
jujutsu sorcerer he walks away from the defeated
child and tells novara that they need to find
akari meanwhile yuji dashes through the humans
getting massacred all throughout the streets
he wants to help but there isn't enough time to
save everyone in this massive crowd either however
lucy hears a familiar voice that might be able to
save the day toge anumaki my favorite mew arrives
with a megaphone in hand and immediately speaks to
the entire crowd commanding everyone to not move
surely after helping toge rescue the civilians
yuji enters shibuya station at around 10 10 pm
unbeknownst to yuji cho so waits inside the
station to confront his brother's killer
back with nanami he kneels over as he speaks
with nobara and ikari he reveals that the jichi
will be okay but tells the girls to not forget
that ajichi originally trained to be a sorcerer
instead of a manager so how ghosts built kind of
different you know nobara and akari also learn
about gojo's situation something they didn't hear
about as they were indoors during yuji's yelling
nanami asks them to wait for rescue while he
joins the xeno team and heads for shibuya station
nobara wants to go but nanami insists that the
coming battle requires grade 1 and above sorcerers
anyone else would simply be in their way meanwhile
underground maymay comes face to face with ghetto
she's surprised to see him but quickly dismisses
the idea that he could be alive yetu tries to act
friendly but meimei hasn't forgotten about abina
geta replies that he feels sorry that he has to
kill a former friend and summons the special grey
disease curse the smallpox deity to do it for him
instead maymay is surprised to see him use
cursed manipulation but still doesn't doubt
her conclusion about him for a moment ghetto
reveals that he doesn't have many curses
left after the attack on jiu jitsu tech in the
previous year but the ones he does still possess
are ones of pristine quality he leaves the area
telling may that if she can exercise this smallpox
deity then he'll be her next opponent the disease
curse immediately activates its domain expansion
trapping meimei inside a coffin the cursed chant's
grave causing a large gravestone to fall from
the sky onto the coffin the curse then begins
to count but maybe breaks out before it ends
wee-wee initially watches in horror but is
excited to see her sister survive maymay is
impressed stating that it's been longer than she
can remember since her life had been in danger for
even a moment at the entrance to shibuya yuji runs
inside and immediately finds choso who recognizes
him as his brother's killers he activates his
blood manipulation convergence then uses the
secret technique of blood manipulation called
piercing blood the ability shoots a condensed
cursed energy reinforced arrow extremely fast at
yuji yuji is able to block it but the attack is so
fast and nearly passes completely through his left
arm yuji tries to close the distance right after
the attack is done and hits him with his divergent
first chozo blocks the hit but is left confused by
the double impact as the fight comes to a pause
chozo asks yuji if his younger brothers left
him with any final words chozo clarifies that he
means the two people yuji killed and their student
laments about what happened with a sad expression
on his face he says that they didn't really have
any last words but they cried before they died
chosen was initially shocked but is then quickly
overcome with rage causing the bloodline going
horizontally across his nose to bubble and distort
in shape chozu asks iso and kichizu to watch over
him as blood behind him forms an intimidating face
shaped by his malice he tells his younger
brother to take a good look at their older
brother as he prepares to kill eugene meanwhile
inside this smallpox deity's domain expansion
maymay is momentarily trapped underground
beneath one of the disease curse's gravestones
the cursed spirit counts down from three again
but meimei breaks out of the trap in time having
experienced this a few times now in the fight
maymay understands the process of the technique
first the target of the domain is trapped inside
a coffin and then buried underground when they're
hit by the weight of their large gravestone lastly
the curse counts down from three and the target
is infected with the smallpox disease the curse
hits mae's coffin with another gravestone but this
time she immediately cuts her way out she believes
this part of the process is the most annoying and
fears she won't be able to fight ghetto freely if
she's hit again may also deduces that the domain
can only target one person at a time and devises
a counter-attack centered around that the curse
instinctively targets the person with a stronger
cursed energy and only a single crow was caught
inside the domain so momma needs the disease curse
to focus on her brother before she can utilize the
birds she asks her little brother if he's willing
to die for her and in his typical simp fashion
he agrees to do anything for her mammy flees
off to the side while yuyu flares up his curse
energy the disease curse notices the swelling
energy and traps wee-wee inside of a coffin
a single hit by the gravestone would be
enough to kill him but as the cursed chant
maemae suddenly slices off its hand with her axe
the grade one sorcerer tells the disease curse
that her brother's role is more of that than
just a pack mule you know i highly doubt but
he then proves this by activating his new shadow
style simple domain to protect himself when mae
mae asked if he was willing to die he realized
that this meant he was actually allowed to fight
mames says that his role is to counter domains
as she doesn't like to be indebted to anyone the
special grey curse disease heals its hand quickly
and reaches out to attack meimei when suddenly the
single bird flies through the back of the cursed
spirit piercing and exercising it in a single blow
while the cursed bird is dying mammy asks the
quickest way to raise one's strength as a sorcerer
and her brother replies that it will be a binding
vow with one's life as they trade off for more
power meimei's extension technique bird strike
exceeds the limits of the crow's cursed energy by
forcing it to commit suicide with a kamikaze-like
attack no one other than satoru gojo has ever
survived the devastating attack with them defeated
maymay declares it's time for the main act
she calls a flock of crows to her side that fill
the underground subway and asks if they're ready
to die for her from these shadows big brain ghetto
comes to confront her admitting that she's not bad
for a jujutsu sorcerer of this era back in the
heat of battle against yuji chozo uses blood
manipulation to control the blood outside of his
body and shoot his piercing blood attack at yuji
yuji quickly realizes it's too fast and his
chances of avoiding it are only about 50 percent
muji instead decides to dictate the timing of his
opponent's next attack by jumping off the ground
this successfully baits choso who willingly
fires passing blood again at yuji's head
just before he hits the ground however yuji
drops his upper body's weight all the way down
close to the ground at the very moment his
feet touch it quickly avoiding the beam
he then immediately rushes towards choso and
attempts to close the distance between them
chozo commends yuji and bends the beam down to
try and hit him yuji though is from the land of
weaving leaving and is able to dodge it then
engages choso at close range he wants to turn
the exchange into a fist fight but there's still a
few floating balls of condensed blood around them
chozo activates supernova detonating all of the
condensed blood in every direction like a buck
shot severely injuring yuji's back big brochuso
follows up by using blood edge to stab yuji's
foot with a dagger made of blood however yuji
surprisingly fights back with his stabbed foot
and kicks him away then using his athletic ability
to flip around chozo's guard he lands a heavy axe
kirk yuji realizes that there aren't any more orbs
of blood and focuses on stopping him from making
any more he's caught off guard though when cho
so assumes the stance for shooting passing blood
giugi stops running towards his opponent falling
for chozo's feigned josue then takes the offense
of casting flowing red scale on himself and
delivering several successive blows to yuji
after smashing him up against the wall chozo uses
convergence and piercing blood to try and finish
him off however our goat somehow has the skin of
a freaking rhino and survives chozo though admits
the blood wasn't condensed enough to kill him
still heavily injured yuji starts to realize he
can't win when randomly once again mkhimaru starts
speaking asking what's going on he replies with
his own question asking where mikamaru has been
this whole time but he claims that he's conserving
energy because there's something he still needs
to do chozo watches confused while mikamaru
recognizes the death painting and tells yuji that
choso is using blood manipulation which is like
pretty obvious he says the inherited technique
is prized within the kmo family for its overall
balance in combat yuji doesn't find this info
helpful as he just narrowly dodges another shot
of piercing blood mikumaro advises him to retreat
to the bathroom revealing that he has an idea yuji
darts into a small hallway surprising cho so the
death painting believes that yuji will head to the
end and skew it up by piercing blood however chozu
runs into the bathroom where he finds mkhimaru's
communication puppet on the opposite wall chozo
uses piercing blood to destroy the puppet but
water certainly bursts out of every opening yuji
who was hiding in their store behind choso attacks
him choco slides back after blocking and believes
that that was yuji's last chance before death
he prepares to use the condensed blood
floating around him to finish the fights
but the water splashing around the room abruptly
dispels convergence chozo doesn't quite understand
what's happened and honestly it kind of took
me a little while to probably get it as well
but he decides to use flowing red scale stack
either way focusing on controlling all of the
blood within his own body to fight instead hugh
doesn't get the logic behind it either but he
does understand that they are fighting where he's
comfortable now in close quarters they engage in
a quick exchange of blows with yuji gaining the
upper hand however just as yuji gets the advantage
chozo used his enhanced strength to flick a
small blood meteorite straight into yuji's liver
yuji is taken off guard because he thought cho
so was out of projectiles thanks to mkhimaru's
water track but immediately he recognizes he's
been hit in an internal organ and considers the
thought of losing and even dying however he stomps
on the damn ground and regains his footing this is
like honestly our boy's time freaking shine right
here yuji converts his fear into curse energy and
clears his mind of all distractions getting ready
to truly die if that's what it takes to bring down
cho so at the same time chozo laments about how
yuji has only landed three significant strikes yet
he is moderately injured from them he knows using
another surprise attack with blood meteorite won't
work so he improvises and hardens his entire fist
and much of his forearm using the blood inside of
his body by doing this chosen was actually at risk
of spontaneously developing a thrombosis but he
determines that yuji is more of a severe threat by
the way thrombosis occurs when blood clots block
veins and arteries which can like result in death
because it can't flow properly around the body i'm
pretty sure yuji and choso exchange blows once
again but yuji is able to predict his opponent's
movements at close range he avoids a punch and
a sweeping kick before hiding in a bathroom door
and locking it this confuses cho so but yuji
suddenly bursts through the door and drop kicks
him in the face chozo narrowly blocks with his
heart in hand but yuji locks his leg around his
opponent's head and throws him when they flying
says a takedown while choso is staggered yuji
closes the existence and flashes his right hand
as a decoy to land a hard left blow to the body
however something just doesn't feel right to yuji
and chozo abruptly cracks his collarbone with a
violent hammer fist to the shoulder this creates
a gaping dent where yuji's shoulder should be
leaving him vulnerable to chozo's next attack the
death painting finishes the fight with a crushing
blow to yuji's stomach that sends him across the
room crashing into a wall chozo lifts his robe
and reveals that he had hardened part of his body
yuji attacked saying this yuji falls unconscious
still barely breathing chosen wants to finish him
off and before doing so tells the jutsu sorcerer
to ask his brothers for forgiveness on the other
side however something freaking mental suddenly
stops cho so like i'm gonna leave you all freaking
confused until probably the next jujitsu kaizen
explain video where i go over the next heart
this like moment is freaking huge at that moment
a memory was born inside of chozo's brain a memory
of a past event that never happened sukuna watches
this from his innate domain disappointed with
yuji's performance he calls his student worthless
and can't believe he lost to such an inferior
opponent suddenly chosu's head begins to throb
and he stumbles away from yuji abruptly stricken
with a headache he recalls eating peacefully at a
picnic table with all of his brothers somehow
including our boy yuji they were both eating
together with iso and kachizu as well as all of
the other six brothers who were still sealed yuji
even passed him some food and called cho so his
big broho so yeah obviously i joked about big
bro choso but maybe i wasn't at the end of the day
maybe big bro toto and choso is a thing who knows
when the memory ends joseph bends over forward
as sweet drips profusely off of his face
he doesn't understand what's going on and asks
himself why yuji was a part of that recollection
as chozo stumbles away confused mimiko and
hanukkah appear to feed one of zacuna's
fingers to the unconscious yuji yo it's time
it's time at 10 20 pm nanami and these enemies
head towards basement floor 5. nanami informs
them about gojo ceiling and ghetto's involvement
naobi mentions he wouldn't mind the decline of the
gojo family prompting maki to tell him to leave
if he's not going to help the head of the xenon
family believes mahi is the one who should go home
nanami actually even agrees with naobito having
left nabarro behind due to the danger of this
mission maki though believes she's more useful
than her drunken grandfather irritated by hearing
this nanami asks naobito if he's been drinking and
the sorcerer claims he's done nothing of the sort
as they reach the lower floors of the station
nanami thinks maybe he should have gone alone
maki notices something while he running through
and an army says it as well an octopus-type curse
hiding behind one of the pillars in the open
area nanami draws his sword and prepares to
exercise him when suddenly naobito appears behind
the curse he traps the premature digon in a frame
using his cursed technique and while immobilized
he lands a heavy strike that sends the kurds
flying across the room the impact severely injures
the cursed womb causing him to vomit up skeletal
remains of the non-sorcery humans he ate earlier
writhing in pain dagon calls out to his allies
including hanami however after realising hanami is
dead it enrages him and forces an evolution degon
leaves his cursed womb behind and evolves into
a much larger and fishier form as he generates
a sphere of water on the top of his finger naobito
prepares for the incoming attack endagon unleashes
a furious current that floods the entire area maki
stabs her spear into one of the pillars and stands
on top of it to avoid the water she's shocked by
the pure volume of the water the cursed spirit
is outputting however much of the water that
comes near beethoven's way is trapped within
the frames made by his cursed technique neobizu
asks the cursed spirit if he knows how many frames
there are in an animated sequence while de gon is
distracted by the old man nanami gets above him
and strikes using his ratio technique digon
appears to block it but he's abruptly seen
crashing into the ground nanami attempts to follow
up with an attack of her own but dagon grabs the
blade of her curse tool before her counter-attacks
naobito traps him inside a frame though and an
army dives down to strike the cursed spirit yet
degon is able to protect himself by generating
a whirling shield of water that circles around him
maki laments being saved by now beto humiliated by
the fact she would have died if he hadn't stopped
a gun earlier the old man playfully slaps dagon's
shield of water and commends him for being able
to pull off multiple simultaneous curse techniques
he recognizes the gon has massive amount of cursed
energy and likely more techniques up his sleeve
in order to counter neobizo leads the way and
claims they'll all crush him with speed before
he can activate any more moves naobiso nanami and
maki all start attacking dagon's watershield as
fast as they can in rapid succession each of them
gradually begins to pierce into it until naobizu's
first breaks through completely before he's hit
dagon causes the water to explode as a distraction
and levitates above making an army however now
naobito suddenly appears behind a gone saying
he foresaw the curse attempting to flee up high
he kicks the gun onto the ground and follows up
with a barrage of brutal blows that overwhelms
the curse dagon admits that the old man is the
main problem in this jiu-jitsu battle and that
he's even faster than joe go he then attempts to
form his fingers together to create a hand sign
but now beto unleashes a flurry of punches that
pounded gone into the ground despite now beto's
best efforts though an uncanny seal forms under
gone stomach area allowing him to cast his domain
expansion horizon of the captivating skanda inside
this coastal type domain nanami and maki are both
suddenly bitten by piranha shikogami the domain's
guaranteed hit creates first shikigami that don't
even exist until they hit the target which is
honestly like just cracked now be so though is
easily able to counter the domains can't miss
attack with a secret art falling blossom emotion
dagon figures that the head of the xenon family
had some kind of trick up his sleeve considering
his skill level because of this he decides to
focus seventy percent of his power on naobiso and
the other thirty percent on an army man obviously
just completely thrilled about maki he unleashes
his death swarm technique calling upon a swarm
of shikagami to attack his foes knowing that
shukigami will instantly eat them alive he warns
maki to attack without hesitation his warning is
interrupted though when the shukugami abruptly
appear to devour him first naobi manages to resist
the wave of shikagami using fallen blossom emotion
but still recognizes the situation does not favor
him he notices that the force of the shukigami
isn't slowing down at all and wonders about the
technique connected to the domain his thoughts
are abruptly stopped though when dagon hides in
the stream of shukigami and punches naobi so high
into the air as he continues to get attacked now
in the air dagon reveals death swarm as an endless
stream of shikagami that will never stop dagon
turns to maki and says that she's the weakest here
he quickly gets behind her and kicks her
hard into the forest area on the beach
despite the heavy hit maki survives and tells the
octopus to finish her off in one hit if he's going
to insult her strength as the gun threatens to
give her the same fate as the other two the new
generation sasuke and his domain expansion chimera
freaking shadow garden is suddenly activated
instantly getting dagon and maki's attention
megami appears from the geyser and calls out
to our girl he extends his shadows out to her
allowing maki to pick up this special grey curse
tool playful cloud grateful for the help maki
tells megami that he really is a cocky brat
momentarily floating above the tornado of shadows
megami looks onward over the coastal area and
notices to gone he immediately recognizes that
the octopus like curse is the master of the domain
de gon believes megami is foolish for entering
his domain voluntarily and prepares to attack him
maki quickly attacks dagon with the playful cloud
striking away a chunk of the cursed spirit's arm
dagon is surprised that he was actually injured
and maki follows up with another blow that seems
to gone skidding across the ocean water he
recovers from the attacks and recognizes
that his guaranteed hit has been nullified because
of mega me locked in her domain tug of war dagon
decides it's best to crush mega mead before doing
anything else the cursed spirit spawns fish from
his body and sends him swimming through the water
at his adversary nanami jumps across the toads
manifested from megami's chimera shadow garden and
slices are partly fish making me a surprise to see
him and nanami asks him about yuji and eno megami
informs him of their status and an army focuses on
protecting megami so he can concentrate on keeping
the domain open dagon is shocked nanami managed
to withstand death swarm for an entire minute
suddenly naobito appears behind him and attacks
with blinding speed the gun ducks under the attack
and is equally surprised that the old man has
survived as well maki comes up to attack behind
the curse and the gun defends by spawning two
large eel-like shrigami to repel these sorcerers
naobitsu traps the one attacking him in a frame
and crushes it with a powerful stomp maki defends
himself as well and they both stand on opposite
sides of the gun now betsy tells him that all his
attacks did was get one arm he adds that even if
he was old and decrypted it will still cost the
curse dearly nanami continues defending megami
but the young sorcerer is reaching his limits
megami reveals that he's actually trying to open
a hole in the domain's barrier rather than engage
in a domain battle the octopus curse likely can't
cast domain expansions twice in the same day so
if the jiu-jitsu sorcerers can escape they win
nanami makes sure megami doesn't plan on staying
behind and the student clarifies that he has no
intention of throwing his life away nanami calls
out to the zenings and tells them to assemble in
a roundabout way they put their trust in nanami's
words and rush towards him digon is confused for a
moment but he quickly figures out his adversary's
plan he panics and rushes to stop them nanami
believes it's too late as a hole appears in the
ground below megami that leads outside of the
barrier you guys let me have clue what's about to
happen if you haven't read this before like hold
on to your damn seats as everyone assembles okay
as everyone assembles around this hole something
unexpected happens before the sorceress can even
exit the domain toji my father himself fushiguro
suddenly enters through the hole and they're
all forced to be a witness to the flesh of the
man who was truly free in all of his overwhelming
intensity toji makes his way into dagon's domain
through the hole that megami had made in the
barrier surprise megami looked up at the man
floating in the air maki notices the intruder
is a human jujutsu sorcerer and dagon wonders
why his adversaries would let someone in rather
than escape then in an instant toji disappears
from sight suddenly grabbing on to playful cloud
with blinding speed he easily snatches the curse
tool from maki throwing her aside to arm himself
with a playful cloud maki didn't even notice
any cursed energy so she's shocked that she
actually lost in an exchange of pure strength
megami then reveals that the hole he had just
opened in the barrier has been closed and it won't
be easy for him to open another neo beto is the
only one amongst them who recognizes who toji is
upon uttering his name naobito notices the sclera
of toji's eyes filled completely with black though
ogami's science technique had the capability to
continue after death it was never meant to last
forever the technique is supposed to end when
the host's cursed energy runs out however the
grandson's soul did not possess any cursed energy
as well and toji's body that overwrote it did not
consume cursed energy therefore it will never end
and now toji can only fight completely on instinct
until the vessel breaks here's a puppet of pure
carnage and destruction the con honestly messes up
really bad like right here he notices toji has no
cursed energy and says that he's a complete waste
of time he summons the shukigami to attack batoji
obliterates it in a single swing with insane speed
he then follows up with a barrage of three section
staff strikes that injured a gun's head sending
him flying back surprised the gun recognizes that
he grossly underestimated toji superhuman speed
and power he tries to summon a swarm of numerous
smaller shikigami to attack but toji continues to
get faster while running on water like the god he
is toshi effortlessly rushes through all of the
fish striking them apart with a curse tool on his
way to attack dagon dagon then summons his hardest
and most powerful shikagami to repel toji however
it's dispatched just as easily as the rest it's
explained that playful cloud is the only special
grey curse tool without a curse technique imbued
into it it is pure and solid power that depends
entirely on the wielder's strength in toji's hand
he annihilates dagon's watershield in a single
blow slamming the curse's head violently into the
sand dumbfounded by the newcomer's domination maki
can only watch in amazement with everyone else
she asks naobita who the man is but he says that
toji is just a ghost nanami tells megami to hold
on to his domain for just a little bit longer
because they're going to need a bet on toji
back with toji he rubs playful cloud together to
sharpen its shape injured dagon barely stands back
up and comes to the realization that he's really
about to lose to a human without any cursed energy
he attempts to buy time until megami's domain
runs out by levitating in the air but once
again naobito is way ahead of him now beto leaps
on top of dagon's head and stops his progress
seeing this toji stacks playful clouds three
sections on top of each other to vault himself
into the air directly and dagon the curse puts up
his guard but toji stabs playful clouds straight
through his face dagon believes he can still
fight but toji brutally threads playful cloud
through dagon's head and stabs him in the eye
as well he then breaks the chain connecting
the three section staff together and rapidly
uses both sharpened sides to obliterate to gone
actually like shanking the shikigami to death
the domain is dispelled and maki is shocked
that one lone fighter was able to exercise
such a powerful cursed spirit single-handedly
megami is exhausted from holding his domain for
so long and takes the moment to catch his breath
nanami knows that if megami hadn't shown up they
would have all been killed but now they have a new
problem they can't be sure if tochi is on their
side or not toji is still fighting on instinct
bearing his fangs at the strongest person around
megami may be exhausted but he's by far the least
injured so toji drags him outside of the
station in an instant before megami can
even process what's happening he finds himself
outside on the road megami lands safely but he
looks back across his street at his opponent
with a surprised expression he claims that this
ridiculous level of speed even past his soconus
from back when they fought earlier in the series
honestly love how megami doesn't even realize that
this guy's actually his dad i really really can't
wait for the day in the series where he finally
finds out who toji fushiguru is or like who toji
zenan is because that's who he knows them as
i'm pretty sure maki yells out of concern for
megami but she's immediately interrupted by a new
presence behind her jogo arrives mourning to gone
and bidding farewell to his friend joku tells
dagon to leave the race to him and then he looks
forward to their reunion and their wastelands
with the next second jogo then has his palm
placed on an army's waist he says that's one and
blasts him with an explosive wave of cursed flames
before maki can even yell out djoko lights her
on fire as well he says that's two and moves to
claim a third victim however naobiso gets behind
jojo surprisingly curse with his speed neo-beto's
innate technique projection sorcery divides a
single second into 24 frames and uses his field of
view as the projection's angle of view by doing so
naobito can trace a predetermined set of movements
to perform within those 24 set frames additionally
anything touched by naomi's palm who doesn't abide
by the 24 fps rule while moving will be frozen in
an animation frame for one second so pretty much
they have to do the exact same thing as naobi
two otherwise they'll be frozen in a frame and
he'll be able to hit them the predetermined set of
movements cannot be adjusted once started and its
trajectory cannot excessively ignore the law of
physics now beta was born with a natural sense of
strategic timing and movements so much so he was
then the fastest jiu jitsu sorcerer excluding gojo
that being said this was when naobito still
had both arms which is kind of like a big
uf moment right there two small volcanic openings
suddenly appear behind neobito and he cannot avoid
the crossing heat waves in time so he is heavily
burned by jogo's technique jogo says that that's
three and prepares to finish off now beto when
zacona's strong presence abruptly gives him the
chills and grabs his attention meanwhile nanako
and mimika remember what was going on with that
with sakura's finger they force feed him one of
zacona's fingers and jojo then finds them soon
after so those battles were like kind of going on
simultaneously so you kind of get an understanding
of how like the fights are working right now
things are going on at the same time as this is
going on so it's all very very confusing annoyed
he demands to know how many fingers they feed him
but the girls quickly flee while zukun's marks
still remain on yuji's face joker decides to make
the best of the situation he too informed
joko beforehand that if yuji ate a finger
for a day for 20 days he probably wouldn't lose
control of his body to skuna in contrast though
feeding yuji 10 fingers at once might temporarily
force him to lose control joko takes out a small
scroll of 10 fingers and tells the king of curses
that it's time for him to wake up oh yes it's that
time of the freaking battle it's time for the man
himself joko looks over to see mimiko and nanako
they're alive but they didn't manage to escape the
station completely joko also notices that their
faces indicate they're afraid and surmises that
they likely can't use another cursed technique to
get out of harm's way while he was distracted
though the silly volcano doesn't even realize
the hand holding yuji's face had been cut clean
off jojo and the girls are both shocked as an
ominous voice demands him to move drago darts
away to position himself next to the sisters
he notices that in comparison to gojo sukuni's
aura is filled with an overwhelming malice
honestly i i wonder if something bad happened in
his past that sends the cooner down like an evil
path in comparison to like gojo having like the
good mindset and changing from what he thought
earlier on you know like in the livestock just
an idea because i think i honestly think sakura
used to be a human and he's turned into a cursed
spirit because people became to fear him over time
anyway nanako believes even one movement will
result in instant death she tells herself to
just breathe but she's unsure if even that's safe
sukuna faces them and says they're holding their
heads a little too high the girls instantly
drop along with jogo but his isn't low enough
sukuna creates a giant gash in the wall behind
the trio that cuts off the top of jojo's head
the cursed spirit begins to bleed profusely across
his face asakuna tells him that one knee was still
too high sukuna walks up to the girls and anako
uses this chance to ask kona if he can free
tsuguru ghetto by killing the person inhabiting
his body nanaku claims to know where another
finger is and will tell sakuna in exchange for
helping them sakuna tells the girls to raise their
heads and gives them a smirk suddenly mimiko's
head is severed displeased sukuna asks if nanako
thought she could order him around for just a
few fingers desperate for revenge nanaku aims
his cellphone camera at sekouna and attempts to
activate her innate technique sukuna activates his
first though and slices the top half of nanako's
head clean off he follows up by dismantling her
entire body into tiny cubes then literally slices
her into nothing but a gruesome spray of blood
sukuni catches nanako's phone and surmises that
the camera is connected to her curse technique
saguna says jogo is next and asks what he needs
however joku doesn't claim to need anything this
confuses zakuna and jogo clarifies his objective
is to simply fully revive him joku implores sakuna
to make a binding vow that will let him take over
yuji's body permanently sukuni refuses this though
and reveals he has his own plans surprising
jogo amused by the curse for its desperation
sukuna offers a token of his appreciation for
the ten fingers he challenges jogo to land
even one hit on him if yoga can achieve this
sukuna agrees to work with his group for now
and kill every human in shibuya except for one
to which jogo willingly accepts meanwhile back
with father and son megami tries to visualize
winning but toji is far too much of a monster
to even fathom defeating megami activates his
rabbit escape when both fighters notice sekuna's
presence suddenly appearing in shibuya megami uses
the torrent of rabbits as a distraction to create
distance from his adversary he also summons
toad and asks himself why he just felt sakuna
toji instinctively charges into the swamp of
rabbits and nearly stabs megami with a sharp and
playful cloud but migami dives onto the ground
and avoids hurts running low on cursed energy
megami's sole advantage is that shoko is stationed
somewhere in shibuya flashing over there yaga says
ajiji and eno would both have perished if not
for her but joku says that that's only thanks
to the principal's quick thinking they set up the
station before nanami even contacted them freeing
him to help up with the mission honestly i think
uh i think yaga might actually be the mole who
was feeding stuff to the higher ups and it wasn't
even kakichi in the first place back in the battle
toji chases after megami and nearly stabs him
from behind luckily toad's tongue pulled megami
away down an alleyway to avoid the attack megami
understands that toji made short work of a special
great and his shivagami are no match for him he
needs to focus on sacrificing his body rather than
hijakigami and decides it's best to limit any
injuries to something shoko can quickly handle
as toshi stands at the end of the alleyway megami
surmises that he has to predict his opponent's
timing because of his speed and understands that
any flaws in timing will surely result in death
taji suddenly blitzes megami and nearly stabs
him again but his foot submerged inside megami's
shadows megami summons a sword from his shadows
and attempts to stab toji with it however toji
disappears in an instant avoiding it with insane
speed megami believes that he's out of options
when toji suddenly recalls a memory of his past it
was the time when toji agreed to meet with naobiso
in order to sell his son to the xenon family
toji believed that megami would have potential
and he could possibly make something of himself in
the future toji never fit in but he thought that
it would be the best way to take care of him in
the long run after not speaking any words since
megami met him today suddenly asks megami what
his name is to which the goat answers perfectly
saying fushiguro proud that his son chose for
shiguro over zenon toshi stabs himself in the
head killing his vessel in order to save his
son from his mindless rampage his body collapses
shocking megami with the outcome of it all and
honestly this is why toji is a goat like yeah
he's strong and his battles are probably the most
hype at this point but they do literally killed
himself for his son as soon as he knew it was him
he instantly did it like pure chair dad as soon
as he knew that his son chose fish a girl over
there and he was like yeah man i'm out of here
megami kneels down and examines the body of his
deceased opponent he notices that his face is
changed back into ogami's grandson and admits
he was lucky that this man decided to end it
making me thinks about what naobito said about
toji and what his opponent said about rejecting
the xenons however megami is still injured from
the fight and decides to go see shoko as soon
as possible suddenly mega meets slash from behind
by the [__] creeper shigemo shigemo's nose and
teeth are still broken from his fight with nanami
but he's alive and somehow moving meanwhile the
kusukabe team wanders aimlessly around shibuya and
yumaki confirmed he relocated all of the civilians
somewhere safe and that sato gojo has been sealed
panda believes they need to hurry but kusukabi
keeps coming up with excuses to keep panda's
urgency at bay the kuzukaba team is interrupted
by the appearance of two curse users suda and
negai or suda and niggy i don't know how to say
there are two former commanders of gesso and three
of their foot soldiers are behind kuzukaba and
panda as well kuzukaba relishes the opportunity to
fight with other sorcerers because it can buy him
more time he asks for the sorcerer's motivations
and tells them to take as much time as they want
manami reveals that they've inherited sugar
ghetto's will she and negai intend on helping
big prank gesso now despite mimiko and nanako's
miscavines skipping forward to the conclusion of
manami's story she asks if kusakabe surrenders
kusukaba is disappointed this story finished
quickly but is still happy as the situation is
too good to pass up kusukabe activates the new
shadow style evening moon sword drawing nego takes
that as his enemies answer and begins activating
a technique of his own their fight is abruptly
interrupted by an explosion that detonates an
entire building behind negai there sukuna pummels
jogo through the ear and dominates their fight
as the latter falls injured with blood spilling
from his mouth sukun asks if that's all he's got
and joker replies not yet joker prepares a fire
attack by concentrating flames between his palms
but zacuna uses his innate technique to slash
jogo's arms apart while the cursed spirit is
still railing sukuna smashes his head with
a violent hammer first the impact seems joko
crashing towards the ground but sakura catches
up to him with a quick dive in order to smash
his face directly into the top of a tall building
sukuna and joko crashed through all of the floors
of the skyscraper which severely injures jogo as
the moonlight shines through the broken roof of
the building sukuna looks down on jogo and says
the moon's illumination makes it easier to see
how pathetic he is as joko struggles to regenerate
his dismantled jaw among other injuries he recalls
ghetto telling him his strength is comparable to
sekuna with eight or nine fingers absorbed despite
knowing he'd be outmatched joko contemplates to
himself that he didn't expect the difference in
their strength to be this great sukuna suddenly
appears behind jogo the king of curses grabs his
opponent's collar and lifts him up telling him
to keep going until the fun stops flames erupt
from all of the forcefully opened holes in
the building further destroying the structure
schooner though escapes out of the building into
the street chasing him jogo follows up using
his strongest curse technique maximum meteor for
those who don't know what a maximum technique is
pretty much that there is just like the strongest
kind of like innate or like ability that someone
can use outside of a domain anyway anyway the
kuzukawe team and the curse users around them
notice the battle going on nearby kuzukaba and
panda attempt to flee and are intercepted by nigai
and suda's henchmen suda tells the underlings they
don't have time to fight bakusa kabe quickly cuts
them down with new shadow style bato sword drawing
kuzukawa tells the remaining sorcerers they need
to flee and get away from the fighting special
grades however sukuna appears next to kusukabe
in an instant and says he won't allow any human
to run sukuna declares that all humans in his
vicinity aren't allowed to move until he says
so or else he will kill them this leaves all
of these sorcerers forced to watch as maximum
mesia falls drawing closer to killing them all
a few moments later sukuna finally lets them all
run however this gives them little to no time as
maximum meteor crashes into shibuya decimating the
entire area with its impacts tired from unleashing
his maximum technique jogo stands atop it huffing
for air after catching his breath he smirks and
says even an attack that powerful must have
injured kona so kona's voice tells jojo that it
would only be the case if it hurts he then appears
sitting beside him as if he was never in danger
he asks jogo why he won't use his domain expansion
joku admits he would lose in a domain struggle
between them and takuna believes his lack of
confidence stems from losing to gojo in the past
entertained sukuna stands up and suggests
he begin fighting using joko's specialty
this here is freaking dope by the way man like
like sucuna starts speaking in tongues like we
don't even know what this guy said sukuna does
something like no one even knows yet to allow
him to open and manipulate flames joku was
confused prompting sukuna to realize a curse
spirit wouldn't understand this technique sukuna
tells joko to get ready for a fire-powered battle
sukuna and jogo stand atop the flaming remains of
maximum meteor sukuni creates an arrow of flames
from his palms while jogo swirls his flames into
a small fireball made of compressed energy sukuna
takes aim by keeping the arrow fully formed
between his fingers while and yeah good old gig
couldn't even write it down jogo enters a fantasy
alongside his deceased allies hanami and dagon
death is something humans fear it is a mirror
for humanity and mojito is a manifestation of
that reflection he will continue to grow stronger
joker believes when they're all reborn they'll
become new entities despite this he hopes all of
them will be able to reunite someday sticking to
his ideology to the end drogo says that cursed
spirits are the true humans when randomly sukuna
abruptly enters the fantasy and asks jojo if he
wants her to become human sukuna knows jogo means
he wants curses to take the place of humans
but believes this is foolish joko should have
burned everything to a cinder without a second
thought to reach new heights without ever being
concerned about gojo sukuna believes jogo lacked
the hunger to take a hold of such desires but even
so the battle still entertained him sukuna admits
that compared to everyone else he has fought over
the last millennia jogo isn't half bad he commends
him telling him to stand proud because he's strong
acknowledged for his strength joko sheets a tear
and asks what's going on back in reality sukuna
answers jojo's smoldering corpse claiming that
he doesn't know either immediately after the monk
urumay comes to escort master sukuna which leaves
him surprised as he is someone from the past
elsewhere at 1107 pm exhausted and injured megami
slowly walks away from his assailant he tells
shigemo that the ten shadows technique begins when
the sorcerer who inherited the technique receives
two divine dogs remember this battle was going on
between shigemo and megami in order to use other
shikigami they must be summoned and defeated by
the sorcerer with the help of the divine dogs
this allows the user to gain more shukigami
replacing this method until they can amass up to
10 different ones uninterested in megami stalling
shigemo asks if this sorcerer is done talking
megami crosses the road away from the curse
user leaving the trail of blood behind from his
injuries shigemo notices that megami isn't letting
him get close despite being on his last legs
even so shigemo feels like he won't even need
to finish off his adversary moments later megami
collapses and hits the ground with a hard thund
proving this point megany struggles to get back
up but continues to divulge how his technique
works either way saying that other people can
help with the exorcism ritual but this will
nullify the technique once it is defeated
this makes it a pointless exorcism but
even a pointless exorcism has its uses
gojo sensei explained to megami why the xenon
family and gojo family are on such bad terms
hundreds of years ago the heads of each household
killed each other in a battle the gojo family head
was a limitless user with these six eyes and
the xenon family head possessed the ten shadows
technique saturday implied that megami could
possibly rise to his level one day however in
the present megami still doesn't quite believe
he could become stronger than his mentor so in a
moment of utter despair he decides to use his last
resort as he believes the head of the household at
that time that defeated these six eyes to use the
ten shadows technique this way as well meanwhile
jogo's maximum measure hits the ground in the
distance getting shigemo's attention he asks
himself who this show off could be and megami
redirects his attention back to his explanation
megami finishes divulging his technique by
revealing that a 10 shadows technique user cannot
use the shikakukami unless it has been exercised
however they can be summoned at any time using
an exorcism ritual shigamo turns back around and
notices megami's sudden influx of cursed energy
due to high student claims that not a
single ten shadows technique user has ever
been able to exercise the shikigami he is about to
bring forth megami summons the eight-handed sword
divergent silla divine general maharaga dragging
his opponent into an unbeatable exorcism ritual
shigemo realizes the grim situation he's currently
in and megami who's also on his last legs silently
apologizes to yuji for what he's done then
tells shigemo good luck before passing on
maharaga thumps miguemi aside sending him
into a nearby building and knocking him out
shikuma was shocked by megami's willingness to
sacrifice himself and curses them for it demanding
the juice who saw sarah get back up and stop this
cruel game back with sacona after defeating joko
and encountering urumay he feels something is up
and leaves the monk behind after telling them not
to neglect their preparations sukuna disappears
and the roommate says they'll be awaiting his
return honestly this hero is just kind of like
screaming to me that sekuna knows something about
big brain guido's plans and he might have
even had something to do with it in the past
overall you know what i mean just before maharaga
crushes shakimo sakuna saves the cursed user he
reads this situation instantly and recognizes that
megami is in a suspended state of death to prevent
this sukuni uses a reverse curse technique to heal
megami telling him that there's still something he
needs this student to do shigemo wants to comment
but sukuni tells him to stay there and stay quiet
shakuna surmises that in order to save megami
he needs to defeat the shikagami sukuna takes
his fighting pose and says he'd like to begin the
battle with just a little taste maharaga attacks
swinging down the blade attached to
its fist sukuno blocks with his forearm
creating a shock wave that knocked shigemo
off balance sukuna notices that the blade
is emitting a strange energy and gets out of
the way before it breaks through his defense
while in medea sukuna delivers a flurry of
left-handed punches and follows up by unleashing
his curse technique dismantle which slices the
sugar's body all over while maharaga recovers
from the blows sukuna recognizes the specialized
blade as a curse tool for cursed spirits called
the sword of extermination the blade is enveloped
in positive energy similar to what's produced by
a reverse curse technique if sukuna was a normal
cursed spirit he would have been sliced cleaned
through the eight-handed wheel on maharaga's
head turns suddenly healing all of its wounds
sukuna quickly attacks again but this time his
slashing technique is deflected by the shikigami
surprising him maharaga swings its blade again
and sukuna prepares to block but this time it's
immediately broken and he's sent crashing
through several buildings from the impact
amused sukuna admits that his opponent isn't half
bad in an instant maharaga clears the area it
just hits akuna across to follow up with another
attack it attempts to sub sukuna in the face but
he jumps above the blade kicking his opponent at
the same time sukuna mounts his giant opponent's
arm and places his right arm only shukigami's face
stating that it's his turn now skuna activates his
slashing technique slicing the entire building in
half the impact sends the shikagami falling out
of the structure only for sukuna to follow up and
kick it straight into the ground he lands beside
the sugar and assumes it will heal again based
on his observations the outhanded wheel turns
and all of its injuries disappear just as expected
sukuna compares this ability to yamato noah rochi
for us webs that want to know is like a legendary
eight-headed and eight-tailed japanese dragon
think like arochimaru when he comes out of sasuke
and atachi ends up shanking him with a dopa sword
that's kind of like what i'm thinking here
i'm pretty sure it's taking off that same kind
of idea maharaga's first attack was reinforced
positive energy when that didn't work it adapted
and reinforced its second attack with cursed
energy additionally it was able to see soconus
curse technique and deflect it both of these
things happened after the eight handled wheel
turned for the first time photo's incarnation
of the 10 sacred treasures and the eight-handed
wheel represents a complete cycle of harmony
with this information sukuna deduces that the
shikigami's technique allows it to adapt to any
and all phenomena sukuni admits that if megami
had unleashed this creature when they fought
the first time and may have been able to beat
him he thanks megami for showing him the way and
activates his freaking domain expansion the insane
malevolent shrine man i honestly just love how
much giga goes into depth on japanese mythology
along with like indian and chinese in other like
six [__] cultures and like intertwines them all
into a story like it really reminds me of what it
felt like back when i was a little kid to probably
get into a series like bleach when a roto it's
it's just so good i absolutely love it sukun's
technique is divided into two types of slashing
attacks the default slash dismantle and the other
cleave the latter can be adjusted using cursed
energy to cut down the target in one foul swoop
malevolent shrine unlike other domain expansions
does not manifest a separate space using a barrier
manifesting one's innate domain without a barrier
is akin to painting a masterpiece on ear without
a canvas a truly divine and unparalleled technique
by allowing an escape route from the domain using
a binding vowel sukuna increases the guaranteed
hit accuracy to nearly a 200 meter radius he
narrows down the effective range to 140 meters to
avoid hitting megami but mercilessly slashes the
rest of shibuya apart civilians who are hiding
out nearby after being rescued by any maki
are violently torn to pieces dismantle is used
on inanimate objects while anything with cursed
energy within a range is hit with cleave while
malevolent shrine is active sucuna's slashing
attacks relentlessly cut down on everything within
its guaranteed hits effective range with around
150 meters of shibuya decimated in an instant
zacuna surmises that the only way to defeat
maharaga is to kill it with a new attack before it
can recover however maharaga has not only adapted
to dismantle but to slashing attacks in general
meaning sukhuna needs to act quickly he activates
his mysterious flame technique again and shoots
a fire arrow at the sugigami before it heals
the impact creates a giant barrier of explosive
flame that completely decimates the hellish
creature the king of curses walks back to
megami with maharaga's wheel in hand he
throws the eight-handled wheel past shigemo and it
disintegrates shortly after solidifying sakuna's
victory annoyed sukuna asks shigimo what he's
looking at and tells him to disappear from sight
feeling extremely lucky shigemo runs off excited
to have escaped another dangerous situation
his innate technique stores little miracles from
every day that are released to save his life when
he's in danger the markings under his eyes show
how many miracles are stored but he's not even
aware how it works exactly believing he's escaped
through day with his life shigemo runs off however
his body suddenly sliced apart as he accidentally
runs into sukuna's domain his body gruesomely
falls into two separate pieces and shigemo finally
dies finally out of like every death that has
happened so far throughout the shibuya arc this is
at least one of the most freaking deserved deaths
dude didn't realize his luck ran out after nanami
beat his freaking ass anyway anyway asakuna walks
off he can feel himself finally losing control
and decides to take megumi to where shoko and
the principal are after dropping megami off
sukuni returns to the area in front of shibuya
with his grip over yuji's body loosening he
switches control back over to the brat and tells
him to take a good look as yuji stands there
he's faced with the wasteland that used to be
doganzaka district shigemo's corpse is in plain
view as the first thing for yuji to see as well
initially dumbfounded yuji collapses as memories
from sekouna's rampage invade his mind he vomits
and cries after realizing that sucuna murdered
several people including mimiko nanako and
heavily endangering his friends and colleagues as
tears fall from his eyes and he huffs for air he
tells himself to just die already he frantically
begins scratching around the ground and continuing
to tell himself to die as his grandfather's
words play over and over in his head suddenly
yunji stops and sits still for a moment before
raising his head and declaring that he still needs
to fight meanwhile inside shibuya station the goat
nanami despite being severely injured by dagon's
death swarm and joko's flames is still alive and
somehow walking around with his sword the left
half of his body is completely scorched including
the entire side of his face he walks past a photo
booth while traversing slowly down the hallway
after nanami passes by mojito sneakily watches
a move through the station until the sorcerer
encounters a large group of transfigured humans
after descending the stairs and coming face to
face with his swarm the nami begins to daydream
about malaysia he wishes he could have built a
house on a secluded beach and read the countless
books he never got around to finishing and
admits to himself that he's getting tired
yeah i think i think i'm all about to
hurt your souls with this one here boys
nanami asks himself if he's done enough already
but continues to fight he ferociously slices
through the transfigured humans with his blunt
sword until a familiar hand touches his chest
nanami looks up to see mojito and claims he didn't
know the curse spirit was around mahita replies
that he's been here the whole time and asks if the
sorcerer would like to chat since they go way back
instead of replying nanami looks down and
speaks to you he wonders why he came back to
being a sorcerer himself and asks hayabara what
he was trying to do yuhyubada's spirit appears
and points an army to his right nanami looks over
to find yuji entering the station down the hall
man this is so messed up he tells hayabara that
he doesn't want to end up cursing the young man
so like a damn king in his last moments nanami
smiles to his protege and tells him that he's
got it from here mohito promptly kills an
army by totally destroying the upper half
of his body shocking the poor yuji enraged
in the next moment yuji rushes mojito ready
to take revenge for his fallen mentor mahito
calmly flicks a small transfigured human at yuji
and transforms it into one that can produce spikes
from its head yuji avoids the spike attacks but
mojito uses the transfigured humans to get behind
yuchi and prepare his soul multiplicity technique
he follows up by unleashing body repel a reaction
that's due to the soul's rejection of the fusion
mahito unleashes a long transfigured human
that attempts to bite yuji with its giant mouth
yuji successfully grips its teeth and stops the
attack but mojito appears from inside its mouth
and lands a violent right that smashes yuji's face
and splits it open yuji asks how mojito can toy
so aimlessly with people's lives and the cursed
spirit just laughs at him mojito doesn't look for
a reason and he isn't remorseful in the slightest
the best answer mojito can give is a demonstration
he creates juniper's face with one hand and stabs
it with the other claiming yuji and him are the
same yuji tells mojito he talks too much and
he will ensure that those are his dying words
he removes the blood from his face stopping the
bleeding and revealing a large scar nanami's voice
reminds yucci that he must remain calm so as he
takes his fighting stance he allows cursed energy
to flow calmly from his hands as he's determined
to prove that he is a jejutsu sorcerer mohito
matches yuji by concentrating cursed energy into
his own fists while contemplating his strategy
idol transfiguration doesn't work on yuji so
mojito decides maintaining his body's toughness
is likely what yuji believes is best for him but
instead mojito won't change his soul's shape at
all and now plans to stab yuji through his heart
in one attack but when his fist passes through the
air yuji suddenly disappears from his sight using
the momentum from getting to this lower position
yuji then strikes mojito in the face with the
manji kirk yuji then follows up by front kicking
mojito as well but the curse quickly transforms
his arm into a spiked vine that forces yuji back
impressed mahito admits that his technique wasn't
half bad and announces that it's time to move on
to round two maheso and yuji continue fighting in
shibuya the cursed spirit attempts to slash yuji
but the latter jumps over the attack after missing
maheso runs and uses a delayed transfiguration to
catch yuji off guard he avoids it again and
mohito follows up with a punching attack from
a large enhanced extra arm wrapped around his
torso like he's out of freaking afro samurai or
something with an extra arm yuji catches the
attack and mohito immediately recognizes the
danger this presents yuji counters but mojito
immediately dismembers his own arm out of fear
he runs through the ticker gate and merges
back with his severed arm once they're at a
safe distance mahisu knows attacking directly
is a big risk for him so he decides to stick
to using transferred humans however reducing
risk isn't the only reason for the strategy
mohito then runs into a different area in
the station and disappears from yuji's site
the young student gets spotted by two civilians
who warn him it's dangerous to be lurking around
yuji believes mojito had run upstairs and
tries to tell the two non-sorcerers to hide
suddenly mojito's arm appears from the inside
of their mouths and punches yuji this special
grey climbs out of the man as if he was shedding
his skin and transforms the other civilian into
a sword honestly man like i forgot about this
part like this is the next level sneaker it's
just pure gangster by mojito man like turning a
person's body into a sword is so freaking cool
anyways mojito tells his adversary to work
on his imagination skipping back to nearly
two hours ago in shibuya station around the time
mohito cho so and jogo began their hunt for yuji
in order to find yuji first mojito had split
himself into two presently mojito's other self
encounters nabarra in an alley way she recognizes
him from past reports from ug hido takes it
as a compliment that he's famous but nibara
claims that he's only known for being a coward
amused mojito decides to kill her nabarro tries
to remember what it was like to unleash the black
flash attempting to tap into the core of cursed
energy in a short exchange nabarro manages to get
the better of mojito using clever explosions
of her pins and the environment around them
he admits that she isn't half bad but doesn't
believe her attacks can actually bring him harm
the cursed spirit understands that nobara is an
ally of yuji's and plans to bring her corpse to
him and destroy his soul so yeah get ready at 11
14 pm after nanami left nobara and akari behind
the first year student refused to leave
with the paramedics team they didn't
tell nabarro that shoko was in the shibuya
district so she didn't do anything reckless
however she ignored nanami's orders to stay out
anyway and went off alone back on the clock at
11 20 pm inside of this station mojito skewers
three innocent civilians and uses them to attack
yuji as he comes up the stairs luchi checks
on the conditions of one of the injured people
only for them to transfigure and explode their
blood gets in yuji's eyes leaving him vulnerable
to an attack from behind mojito transforms his arm
into a spike's club and prepares to finish him off
meanwhile in an alley nearby mohito is still
clashing with nobara she avoids his hands but
mohito's double can't transfigure other solves
anyway this double attacks by transfiguring
himself since this isn't yuji and he doesn't
incur any risks novara tries to trade blows but
it doesn't seem to work mojito casually avoids
nabara's projectile nails as she climbs up the
side of the alley onto a higher platform she drops
several nails at mojito's feet and detonates them
with the hairpin before coming back down confusing
mojito with her movements while he's focused on
herbara she activates hairpin again and her cursed
energy extends them into mojito's lower body
immobilizing him novara mounts mojito while he's
injured but he doesn't see any potential danger
regardless however unbeknownst to the special
grade nabarro has figured out a way to attack
his soul mojito realizes nabara was bluffing
about not having a plan but it was too late
she hammers a nail directly into his forehead
and activates resonance by using mahito's body as
the effigy nibara can use her curse technique to
attack his soul as a result resonance also relays
from the double to the original soul and rebounds
the damage back greatly injuring them both back
in the other fight this injury just happens to
stop him from finishing yuji off yuji manages
to open his eyes and recognizes nabarro's needle
sticking out of the curse's chest mahiro's double
is shocked and realizes that yuji isn't his only
natural enemy the girl of steel standing before
him can attack his soul as well nabarro reveals
that she felt her cursed energy activate somewhere
else nearby additionally she doesn't feel
mojito's curse energy is as strong as it should be
she surmises that mojito is simply a double
that can't properly use his innate technique
amused mojito licks the blood dripping from
his face and admits his adversary is completely
correct recognizing his classmate's curse
technique yugi capitalizes and pummels mojito
with rapid fire cursed energy infused punches
while yuji bashes mojito into a pillar with a
relentless barrage he solemnly thanks nabarro
yuji believes he hasn't been able to save anyone
and that he's wasted everyone's efforts but
novara's help has shown him he's still not alone
inspired by nabarro yuji keeps the pressure on and
prepares to exercise mojito here and now meanwhile
in the alley the nail drops from mojito's doubles
forehead as he affirms her theory about him nobara
believes the real duel begins now but the double
decides to run away instead and heads directly
into the subway entrance novara could just ignore
him but she has a bad feeling about letting him
run loose and decides to exercise him before yuji
can finish off mojito's main body the special
grace splits into several small spherical versions
of himself that run across the room one of them
flares up its cursed energy as they faint to get
yuji's attention and allow the others to escape
the other devils then reform into mojito's body as
he runs away both mojitos enter the same corridor
with their 2jiujitsu high students chasing them
yuji initially believes mojito is trying to heal
until he sees nobara he immediately yells for her
to run away realizing the danger she's suddenly in
since maheso isn't able to use the idol
transfiguration technique on yuji he made the
second body that can't use idol transfiguration
attack yuji and his other body that can use idle
transfiguration attack nobara as nobara and mojito
fight he was able to touch her and used his idol
transfiguration nabarro holds her face and recalls
everyone in the village she was from being crazy
she used to believe that lots of people were
crazy and got in the way of other people's lives
but that was until she attended jiu jitsu high and
learned that being crazy isn't so bad after all
she pictures the images of all of her friends and
apologises to fomey for being unable to meet her
again in the future nabarro looks at yuji and
tells him to make sure everyone knows it wasn't
so bad and as she says that nobara's face swells
up around her left eye and bursts from the effects
of mojito's technique yuji watches in horror as
nobara's eye shoots violently out of her head
and her blood splatters on his face novara
lays before yuji missing an eye and likely dead
losing to choso sokuna's rampage and nanami's
death had already taken a toll on yuji's resolve
having reached its limit a long time ago yuji's
spirit breaks after nobara is unable to answer
and he desperately screams her name this douche
happy with himself commends his own talents and
believes he is a true curse he then successfully
unleashes a damn black flash on yuji just to
follow up on his already dying soul mojito's black
flash sends yuji crashing through the station
this special grey continues to beat on him while
exposing yuji's determination for being weak
mojito believes that it isn't simply a battle to
fix something this is a war of truths he believes
yuji is the same as him because he kills without
hesitation just as yuji saves people without
a second thought i truly do love how well
mojito like has been written as a character
like i freaking hate this guy so damn much like
damn damn dude mohito believes that this conflict
will determine which of the two remains 100 years
from now after thoroughly beating yugi down both
mentally and physically mahito asks this student
how he ever planned on winning and if he's ever
counted how many curses he's exercised has never
cared about how many people he's killed and he
believes he'll forget about yuji eventually he
morphs his arm into a praying mantis like claw and
attempts to kill yuji however there is a clapping
noise and suddenly mojito is displaced you guys
know what freaking time it is right now our boy
our brother toto the eternal brother appears just
in time having used bogie woogie to switch places
with mojito he says that the prosperous have no
choice but to eventually decline neater also joins
the scene after treating obara toto mostly tells
him to help his brother yuji nix before telling
his nearly defeated friend that he must wake up
helpless and trembling on the ground in front of
them yuji explains that he cannot fight anymore
not only did nobara perish in front of his
eyes but nanami was killed by mohito as well
to where to yuji's suffering sucuna slaughtered
potentially dozens of people and yuji felt he
needed to help others to compensate however he
feels he failed completely crying and withering
on the ground yuji expresses that he simply
can't forgive himself enticed by yuji's suffering
pedo jumps at the group of sorcerers with his
arms shaped into a thorned like weapon toto claps
his hand and activates boogie woogie to switch
mojito's position in the air with a rata behind
him mohito attempts to turn around and attack toto
but the student suddenly switches the cursor's
position with yuji taken off guard mojito is
left wide open to a powerful kick that sends him
railing towards errata toto quickly swaps a writer
and mohito again and takes position in front of
his juniors to face off against his special grade
alone now what an absolute g man mojito laughed
and admits to himself that toto is extremely
disorientating at the same time todo tells yuji
that he believes as long as they keep on living
those who have passed on will never truly have
been defeated he adds that looking for logic and
meaning and death can defile the memories of the
dead but todo still asks yuji for what he's been
entrusted with todo tells yuji that he doesn't
need to answer him right now however until he
does the first year can never stop fighting
he expresses this to yuji and runs ahead to fight
mojito alone irata quickly treats yuji's injuries
by applying his curse technique he informs yuji
that his injuries won't get any worse from here on
out unless he sustains new ones arata has already
done the same for nobara he admits that she didn't
have a pulse and isn't breathing but encourages
yuji by adding that there is a chance of survival
arasa then takes nobara and retreats out of this
station mahito attacks toto and tries to split
himself into a few different ways to outmaneuver
his opponent however toto proves to be too
efficient at avoiding mojito a small transferred
human behind toto transforms into a large spike
by the third year avoids the attack mojito
is disappointed his opponent didn't even clap
even so he's confident after tapping into the
power of black flash he believes it's drawing
him even closer to the true essence of his soul
toto suddenly claps and interrupts mojito's train
of thought yuji appears before the cursed spirit
back in the fight he charges his fist with cursed
energy and reminds himself of nanami's last words
focused and recommitted omni battle yuji unleashes
black flash on mojito destroying the curse's arm
mojito is knocked back but quickly heals his wound
amused the curse smiles and says that yuji
is back from the dead toto welcomes him back
into the battle as well and usually stands ready
to fight beside him elsewhere on a train meewa
holds one of mikamaru's communication devices in
her hands she's disappointed as kokichi's voice
informs her that the shibuya incident will be
settled at any moment now he tells her to turn
back because it's too late but kasumi ignores him
and asks why he only allowed toto and arata to go
kikichi doctored the record so that everyone else
shown the group including udahime would be away
from shibuya on october the 31st absolutely
lad man kasumi asks if she's useless and weak
since he didn't entrust her and everyone else to
go she argues that he's the weak one and admits
he made mistakes that he couldn't even go through
with he confesses that there was someone he loved
and believed they would be fine regardless of
the state of the world as long as they were
together with his time running out kikichi
says his final goodbyes to meewa as she cries
kikichi asks her to find happiness and adds that
as long as she does that his wish will have come
true for a moment kikichi appears sitting next to
her in the reflection of the window as he says his
goodbyes his image disappears for the last time
as she looks up into the window the other members
who were left outside the incident can hear
meewah sadly crying from elsewhere on the train
mai asks udahime about mkhimaru's betrayal but
odahime doesn't believe it matters since kikichi
was killed kamo is disappointed mikamaru
expected so little from them but momo is
simply enraged that he made her junior cry if
only they understood man what was really going
on meanwhile the battle between mohito and the
juju sorceress rages on with his fighting spirit
reignited yuji fights effectively alongside
toto to keep mojito on the defensive mojito
knows toto's soul is at full strength and one
transfiguration might not be enough to kill him
yuji's soul is much less stable but mojito isn't
exactly in great shape either he feels at less
than half of his full strength after having his
double destroyed and being hurt with a black flash
nato plans to deal with toto switching first and
tries to use a transferred human to distract yuji
however maher was surprised when toto uses boogie
woogie to swap places with the transfigured human
this allows him to get behind mojito and force the
curse to destroy his own weapon at the same time
toto thinks about feeling like he's being left
behind now that mojito can use black flash as well
yuji refused to get left behind and use the
technique during the goodwill event todo refuses
to let yuji feel alone and finally like the
big brother he is unleashes his own black flash
pummeling mojito with a perfect kick nero's arm is
broken by toto's black flash but he still doesn't
believe toda will be able to hurt him even so this
special grade recognises that all three fighters
have reached 120 of their potential mojito
then voluntarily vomits up several miniature
transferred humans and combines them using soul
multiplicity mohito immediately activates body
repel creating multiple transfigured snake-like
heads that attempt to chomp at his enemies
as the attack breaks through the underground
of shibuya yuji and toto are forced to move and
evade all of the attacks in the air the latter
recognizes that mahito is countering boogie
woogie by attacking from all directions meizo
empathetically tells yuji that it's their last
chance to curse one another asking if the curse is
forgotten about him toto swaps all three of their
positions so he's holding the hato then slams him
head first into the ground yuji attempts to smash
mojito's head with a kick but the curse dismembers
himself to avoid the blow the special grade's body
grows two eyes and transforms its arm into a blade
before rapidly attacking at the same time mojito's
head grows a separate body and stands behind
his other half to activate soul multiplicity
this time mojito combined two souls with weak
rejection to form one powerful transfigured human
using polymorphic soul icy mirror toto uses boogie
boogie to continuously give his side the best
spot against the enemy while believing mohito's
body contains the most of the power but the head
itself is the real hymn because it used either
transfiguration before taking out mojito's real
south turtle attempts to take out the polymorphic
soul isamur however much to his surprise toto is
suddenly smacked aside with a powerful blow the
impact seen some crashing through an entire floor
and out the other side into the road but he still
manages to recover his balance the soul confronts
the sorcerer and toto counter attacks by infusing
a rock with cursed energy and swapping places with
it behind his opponent much to toto's surprise
one hit was enough to kill the soul icy mirror
his surmises that its explosive power was the
result of mojito expanding numerous souls at once
to manifest it there are two more now confronting
him and todo asks for their forgiveness before
taking each of them out while mohito was free of
boogie woogie he decided to pile on the attacks
against yuji he uses a more ferocious version of
body repel to attack but the sorcerer avoids the
attack and drop kits mojito through the air the
curse counters by grabbing yuji's leg and slamming
him onto the ground when the dust settles from
the crash mojito attempts to follow up the attack
however he's irritated to find the top note goat
standing back at his brother's side mohito was
surprised not even two polymorphic isomers were
enough to stall or defeat toto he can't transfer
toto without being able to touch him and sukuni
retaliates if mojito attempts a domain expansion
it's too complex for mojito to exclude yuji from a
domain's barrier so he decides to take inspiration
from the big man himself the duo are both
shocked when mojito suddenly activates
his domain expansion just like gojo mojito
activates his all-or-nothing domain expansion
for 0.2 seconds taking both of his opponents
completely off guard toto acts quickly and
activates a simple domain which he learned from
yuki even faster though is yuji who's already
running towards mojito in an attempt to exercise
them before either transfiguration can activate
however despite their speed mojito was the
fastest the two-step process of realizing
one's innate domain and the activation of their
curse technique are combined into one by mahito
who had awakened through black flash as a
result of activating his domain expansion
mohito enters sakuna's innate domain for a
moment he asks takuna if this is a safe place
and inquires about his agreement with ug the king
of curses remains silent but mohito continues
questioning in order to challenge sakuna he
arrogantly claims yuji will be dead before zakuna
can even switch places with him and tells the king
of curses to just shut up and watch the balls on
the sky man as the self-embodiment of perfection
ends toto's left hand begins to transfigure yuji
turns around to check on his brother but mojito
knocks him to the ground while his back is turned
toto quickly severs his own hand but thus leaves
him vulnerable to the approaching special grade
after activating domain expansion the user's
innate technique becomes difficult to control
mojito became aware of that fact after escaping
against an army he instead attacks todo with a
strong punch enhanced by black flash that sends
toto into relentless pain big brain toto though
instinctively concentrated all of his cursed
energy to defend the blow and minimise all of
the damage medo then becomes able to activate
idle transfiguration again and plans to kill
toto with the next hurts nato's focus though
is suddenly interrupted when toto's necklace
falls onto the ground and knocks open a small
picture frame containing the photos of yuji and
takada while his opponent is distracted yuji uses
mojito's hand to clap and activate boogie woogie
toto instantly switches places with yuji who
strikes mihito in the face with another black
flash toto collapses and looks at his remaining
hand while expressing that he's lucky to be alive
ready to finish the fight alone now yuji looks
back at toto and thanks him for all of his help
final battle shibuya finally begins or is
it the final battle i guess we'll find out
i guess we'll find out next heavily injured mohito
creates a polymorphic isomer to hold yuji off
he admits toto was a problem for him till the
very end but despite his depleting condition
mohito believes he's found the true essence of his
soul yuji defeats the polymorphic isomer and as
this happens medium evolves into the final stage
of his being emerging from a cocoon of probably
cursed stuff you know who knows what it is he
then instantly activates idol transfiguration
on himself making himself into an instant spirit
body of distorted killing this form is just like
super clean man like i said it's probably one of
giga's out of this world type [__] not just a
normal like anime character face i love it like
made up that's probably why i like it in the midst
of these cities ruins yuji glares at his greatest
enemy and wonders what his newest transfiguration
brings the cursed spirit feels reborn and asks
yuji to wish him a happy birthday to celebrate
the momental occasion having unleashed black
flash mojito believes he has tapped into his true
unbridled soul yuji didn't take his adversary to
be won for a self-discovery journey amused maher
replies that only after killing yuji does the
cursed spirit feel that he can truly be reborn
the two fighters instantly blitz one another
to reignite their battle nihiro makes the
first move creating a shock wave with just a
wave of his arm yuji ducks under the wave and
attacks with a straight kick that's caught by
the black heads protruding from mojito's head
the curse tries to take the advantage with a tail
whip but yuji blocks it he is then able to parry
mojito's punch and counter with an uppercut to his
body however yuji's cursed energy infused punch
deals absolutely no damage at all mahiru knocks
yuji away and forces him to realise that the curse
spirit transcended way beyond his former state
they trade blows but yuji's attacks are unable to
reach his opponent any longer yuji is overwhelmed
and slammed into the street creating a giant
crater from the impact the street crumbles apart
and yuji falls down to the bottom as water fills
the bottom of the crater where yuji now stands
across from mojito the former realises he can only
win using a black flash infused punch with maximum
cursed energy mohito attempts to take advantage
of yuji's small laps by rushing in however the
curse spirit immediately stops their tendrils on
the back of his elbows partially disintegrate and
mojito even coughs up blood getting hit by black
flash so soon after deactivating domain expansion
seriously injured mojito amused with their final
standoff mojito wipes the blood from his mouth and
states both of them have plenty left in the tank
mojito rushes his opponent creating a giant splash
and the water from his incredibly fast movements
yuji immediately clenches his fist in his palm
and charges all of his cursed energy into it
mahiru attempts to attack yuji from behind
but the sorcerer ducks under in time the curse
spirit then tries to come adam with a right hook
but yuji uses the back of his palm to parry it
having been hit a bunch now maydo knows that
he's vulnerable to being hit by another one of
yuji's black flash attacks meaning going
in recklessly will only lead to his end
but leaving here's a countermeasure in mind mojito
partially deactivates his distorted killing form
on the left side of his body this special grade
believes yusu will aim at his sweet spot and that
will lead to the chance to counter and decapitate
him yuji indeed does strike a mojito's left side
appearing to take debate but just as mahiru goes
for the kill a second impact throws the trajectory
of the strike off juji ducks unimahido's missed
attack and prepares to deliver the final blow
the curse spirit reinforces the left side with his
instant spirit body of distorted killing and tries
to hit his opponent first suddenly though al go
the broski the bro the brother toto's voice echoes
through the battlefield interrupting mojito's
momentum toto tells the cursed spirit that an
arm is simply a declaration and an act of applause
is an acclamation of one's soul time this man is a
poet man besto frendo uses his freaking amputated
hand to imitate clapping with his remaining hand
trying to anticipate the switch mohito quickly
turns around and attacks he ends up hitting
nothing though and realizes that he's been utterly
fooled by toto one last time toto apologizes and
claims that bogie woogie is already dead yuji
takes advantage of his ally's clever thinking
and strikes mojito with a black flash imbued with
maximum cursed energy the impact from yuji's blow
is so fierce it coats his opponent in a streak
of cursed energy that blasts the cursed spirit
completely out of the crater mohito is heavily
injured and forced out of his distorted killing
form additionally this special grade is out of
transfigure humans as desperation sets infamhito
for the first time in his existence guji stands
over him just as the curse proclaimed earlier
in the fight yuji admits that he is mojito
he no longer requires a reason to kill him
and will exercise curses no matter what form they
take fully aware now that is nothing but a cog and
they struggle between two sides yuji is confident
to play his role as a jutsu sorcerer against the
threat of cursed spirits nato desperately tries
to flee as yuji chases from behind like a wolf
chasing the rabbit through the snow like oh dude
when this when this was going down with the first
time i was freaking screaming and chanting like oh
my god man i can't actually like the pages were on
fire like full on they weren't like seriously oh
my god before yuji can finish my hazel off someone
appears ghetto suddenly appears before mahito
standing over him and looking down on his fellow
special grade flashing away at 10 36 p.m in kuala
lumpur malaysia which you know obviously is a big
shout out to our boy nanami and obviously this
is like where they were going to escape to after
if things went bad i think anyway maymay teased
wee-wee about sharing their bed until someone gave
her a call back she revealed to that person that
she was nearly killed by gesso and had to escape
using wee-wee's technique she advises them to sell
all of the japanese stock and tokyo real estate
immediately having also already exchanged her
yen maima expects a possible negative chain
reaction could still affect other nearby developed
nations japan's economy is the third largest in
the world and could be in for a major decline
around the same time panda located kusaka bay
choso was continuing to have flashbacks of yuji
in his life alongside his brothers after shooting
the tear for his brothers chosen decided he needed
to move unsure of himself now chosun needs to know
what yuji is at 11 36 p.m ghetto asks mojito if he
is in need of saving yuji acts quickly recognizing
ghetto's name and appearance he demands gojo
back and rushes towards the curse user getting
nonchalantly though explains that people of the
mid-edo period spoke of a mysterious connection
between catfish and earthquakes at the same time
he summons a small catfish curse spirit that swims
into the underground suddenly a gigantic hole
created by the curse appears underneath eugene
the first year loses his balance and appears
to fall into the hole however yuji abruptly
falls onto the ground as if the hole never even
existed completely dazing him ghetto asks if
yuji believed he had fallen and says from a side
view it just looked like he suddenly flipped over
he explains the strengths of cursed spirit
manipulation lies in the higher number of moves
at the user's disposal by wielding multiple curse
spirits of semi grade 1 and higher ghetto can
unleash different types of attacks every time his
opponent adjusts ghetto demonstrates this using a
curse that takes the form of a swarm of centipedes
crawling out of a black webbing to ensnare euge
then the catfish curse opens another hole at
the same time suspending yuji in the air without
any balance before stacking another centipede
attack and smashing the sorcerer into the ground
as yuji lays on his hands and knees bloodied from
the attack ghetto realizes that the first year
had nothing to do with the events a year earlier
instead luji simply demands satoru back and ghetto
laughs in response while admitting that tikun's
vessel is tough maheru attempts to hit ghetto from
behind but his hand is easily avoided the cursed
brit admits he knew yuji was tough all along
since he was born from humans ghetto then absorbs
mojito as the cursed spirit utters his final words
standing before yuji holding mojito sealed
inside a black orb ghetto begins to explain
maximum techniques they are innate techniques
most powerful art outside of a domain expansion
cursor manipulation maximum uzumaki combines
the cursed spirits and the user's possession
to unleash a burst of super condensed cursed
energy randomly ghetto begins to laugh yuji asks
what's so funny and the curse user replies that he
accidentally started acting like suguru continuing
on about uzumaki he explains the technique is
powerful but he initially believed and negated the
great number of moves at the cursed manipulator's
disposal guido admits he was wrong about uzumaki
because when semi-grade 1 and high curse spirits
are utilized their curse technique is extracted
pretty much what he means is he's able to use any
curse technique from a semi-grade one or higher
and still use maximum material using all of the
other curses that remain as well plus probably
some of the power from that curse i would imagine
but he won't lose like that ability of like idle
transfiguration or like say any other ability
that he might get in the past ghetto swallows
the black orb containing a hexo officially
adding the special gray to his collection
while looking up gideo tells yuji it's
foolish to think he wouldn't notice
momo is floating above him on her broom using the
lantern as a signal for her allies to attack from
long range kamo is the first to act firing
cursed energy-infused arrows at the enemy
ghetto avoids the arrows but immediately notices
a speeding bullet coming directly at him however
he simply blocks mai's bullets with a curse as
meewa joins the fight she recalls her past and
how she met her mentor in junior high deciding
to become a to sorcerer despite having never
even held a wooden sword meewa quickly slides
in behind ghetto and activates new shadow style
while recalling her blistered and bloodied
hands maybe who puts everything into the swing
she's prepared to never even use their sword
again and attacks with battle sword drawing
however gito simply catches the blade with his
bare hands and shatters it immediately after
negating miiwa's attack guido activates maximum
uzumaki with the technique having been divulged
yuji knows about uzamaki's power and yells for
the curse user to stop momo usually looks down
and moves to save miwa but sadly uzumaki destroys
the ground with a blast of super condensed cursed
energy leaving a gaping hole in the ground from
the impact however the technique didn't actually
hit anyone and ghetto admits that it's nice facing
someone with experience rather than these students
kugosabe was able to use his new shadow style
to cancel out part of the curse technique and
protect maewa at the same time panda arrives
to the battlefield and checks on yuji
he's relieved to see that yuji is back in control
of his body he asks if the cursed user has the
cursed object holding saturday gojo camus asks
who the curse user is and panda can only say
that it's a mysterious person that has assumed the
identity of tsukuru ghetto by controlling his body
suddenly our boy the other brother chosu
arrives on the battlefield surprising yuji
ghetto welcomes him but our boy in the middle of
his like i don't even know if you can call this a
mid-life crisis or curse crisis you guys choose
what one he completely is he's a mix in my mind
still finally recognizes the curse user as one of
his three parents so yeah this is kind of messed
up right man like for real there is uh choices
mother the curse spirit who got her pregnant
which is freaking weird man and the man who tore
me to chose his mother to create the cursed womb
death paintings chozo hated this person and
now that person is inhabiting sukuru's body
this thing is no one other than the most evilest
sorcerer in history the prolific noritoshi
kmo obviously this is kind of uh confusing for
those that are sitting there like yo wait you
say naruto shikemo that's that other dude like it
even it even confuses the students here so i don't
blame you pretty much this dude's just old ass man
like just think of it he's oh he's from the past
he's an old camo udahime clears it up more that
chozo is referring to the stain of the kamo clan
kuzukabe believes that it makes sense for him
to be someone with absurd barrier techniques
cursed objects and the ability to switch bodies
ghetto claims that naratoshi kamo is just one of
the many names he's gone by so possibly the dude
could have even been like far older than we even
suspect at the moment because we don't know where
he started you know where did the brain dude start
from jose rushes at narutoshi however a roommate
abruptly cuts him off sliding next to ghetto and
telling the bottom feeder to step aside ruff arumi
tells cho so not to make them wait any longer but
chozu replies for the curse user to get out of his
way and repeat that he's yuji's older brother so
yeah it's a finally explained here why he thinks
that a side effect of chosen's curse technique
is that he can sense the transformation of his
younger brothers through their blood connection
just before finishing off yuji in their fight
earlier in shibuya choso could feel the sensation
of death coming from yuchi just like he did
with his other brothers tachoso this can only
mean that yuji is also his younger brother by
the way i'm just calling brain dude brain dude
or brain or narutoshi until we know his name i'm
not going to call him kamo i'll just call kamokamo
so it doesn't get confusing yeah narutoshi has
extended his life from moving from host to host
making it possible that yuji and choso could
share some sort of blood relation in order
to fulfill his duty as an older brother chosu
was ready to protect yuji with all his strength
chosu activates blood manipulation convergence
surprising kamo with how superior it is to his own
chosu fires piercing blood and it almost reaches
arumi's face in the blink of an eye the monk is
surprised by the immense speed of piercing blood
and barely manages to stop hurt ghetto sidesteps
the attack while it draws a hole through one
of his partner's cursed energy reinforced hands
chozo swings the stream of blood sending the arrow
back to slash at naratoshi this breaks up the
ground and chozo uses the blood he placed there
to disrupt ghetto's footing they then engage each
other by trading blows in close quarters naratoshi
is the first to land a significant strike and
suggests chozo shouldn't strain himself after
fighting so much earlier on jose doesn't believe
being tired is any excuse to stop putting his
life on their line to protect his younger brother
confused panda asks if yuji is really related to
joso yuji doesn't believe they were related at all
and reveals how chozo had nearly even killed him
earlier which is you know like what the [__] man
regardless of his relationship with yuji norotoshi
points out that choso is creating a disturbance
that they need to take advantage of with two
cores still going strong panda goes out in
full gorilla mode while the others follow behind
him he activates his unblockable drumming beat
but suddenly a roommate activates their innate
technique ice formation urumay uses frost khan
to release an icy mist that freezes cho so
narutoshi panda and kusakabe ghetto asks
them not to kill these sorcerers because he needs
messengers and a roommate heals his hand using a
reversed curse technique discouraging kusakabe who
considers these curse users to be on a whole other
level chosu activates flowing red scale to rapidly
increase his body's temperature and melt the ice a
roommate appears in front of cho so but yuji one
of the only ones who wasn't frozen dropped kicks
choso out of the ice to save him from a roommate
annoyed the monk asks who does the vessel think
that body belongs to yuji believes that he wasn't
frozen judas akuna and asks cho so what side he's
on chozu denies he's fighting with the sorcerers
and states once again he's yuji's older brother he
even asks yuji to try calling him big brother just
once which reminds me i obviously have toto so
hard man yuji ignores this because he notices momo
flying down towards the group on her broom momo
uses her wind scythe to launch a blade of cursed
energy from her broom at the two cursed users
a roommate is able to block this attack with their
bare hands frustrating momo with yuji momo and cho
so the only one still mobile the kyoto student
tells the other two that they need to buy time
for utahime dissatisfied with needing a messenger
as a reason for keeping this many sorcerers alive
aruma activates ice formation they claim yuji
alone will be enough and creates a steam of
icicles that surrounds both curse users and splits
apart to freeze them the flying ice bits attack
and freeze yuji choso and momo in place a second
wave of sharpened icicles attacked them from above
pretty much cementing their deaths until
a mysterious shikagami suddenly appears
to break the ice apart the special grade
sorcerer yuki appears on the battlefield
she asks ghetto the same question again from all
those years ago inquiring as to what kind of girls
he's into so you know like if you're wondering
who toto's taught by it's yuki it's this chick
here the special great sorcery yuki the third
one that we haven't actually properly met the two
sorcerer's clash philosophies regarding the future
of humanity's relationship with cursed energy
yuki believes humans need to break away from curse
energy while guitar believes optimizing it will
bring about the evolution however the world ghetto
pursues would be full of bloodshed because japan
has a virtual monopoly on cursed energy something
like that would cause the other world powers to
retaliate and use humans as an energy source
girl doesn't care if the world ends up that
way he believes there is more to the human
potential beyond sorcerers and cursed spirits
he attempted to create the death paintings to
bring that potential into existence however ghetto
has deemed that a failure and has since realized
that anything he can create on his own does not
exceed the abound of his own personal potential
the answer he seeks is hidden within the darkness
and only the chaos that naratoshi can't even
control can bring it forth he reveals that he's
already extracted the curse technique he needs to
begin this process yuki has a realization and asks
what happened to mojito prompting yuji to reveal
that ghetto had just absorbed him the curse user
remotely activates idol transfiguration on every
human he's marked he thanks yuji for bringing out
mojito's full potential because his cursed energy
stopped improving the moment it was absorbed the
two types of non-sorceries have been marked prior
to the remote casting of idol transfiguration
the first type are non-sorcerers who are meant
to stay as such but instead have awakened new
curse techniques much like juniper this second
are vessels that ingested cursed objects like ug
ghetto's plan is to release a thousand malevolent
sorcerers and get them to fight one another
yuki doesn't believe a thousand rational people
would fight one another to death but it was sure
to her he wouldn't make any over sights annoyed
yuki asks yuji to help her beat up the imposter
yuji can't move though due to the ice holding
him but chozu's poisonous blood abruptly causes
a roommate to collapse down onto one knee and
the ice suddenly starts melting before they
move though guido declares the cursed objects
he provided were created from these sorcerers he
made vows with a millennia ago however those vows
became null when he obtained sukhodogiro's body
yuki understands the implications of this just as
noratoshi announces that this is the world of the
future he shows the prison realm to his enemies
and bids farewell to yuji claiming to expect a
lot from him in the coming times the young man
calls out gojo's name one last time and ghetto or
no ratoshi or brain or whatever finally addresses
sukuna directly he tells the king of curses that
an era reflecting the he and era is coming and
that the golden age of jiu-jitsu is returning so
that officially brings us to the very end of what
is jutsu kaizen shibuya incident arc and obviously
this freaking arc here is actually insane the
stuff that goes down throughout this arc like
the fights between toji and megami and obviously
toji and dagon and the group there and they're
like individual fighting needs to gone and then
the stuff that happens with freaking saturday at
the beginning of the arc with him getting sealed
is obviously like the main big thing with this arc
and then right at the end of it with freaking and
then right at the end of it with freaking sugar
ghetto finally announcing his plan to everyone
which is actually you know like coming to come to
be i guess you could say as that is the result of
what is going on right now and the culling game so
obviously i'm going to move into those up and
coming arcs in the next few videos because i
definitely want to cover more of jiu-jitsu kaizen
i am a little bit behind where the story currently
is but i'm kind of caught up i kind of know
what's going on at the moment so i'm super
excited to be able to actually cover that in this
you know kind of video format that i've been doing
obviously if you guys did enjoy you know this kind
of video and want to see more stuff just like it
where i go over other stories or other arts from
different animes and mangas then make sure you hit
that subscribe button and also be sure to leave
a like on the video and if you want to see more
stuff you know like this but just a fraction of a
time slightly earlier then make sure to check out
my patreon down in the description below where
you can get like i guess little tidbits and uh
updates occasionally of what i'm kind of up to
and if you if you just want to like follow me
and see what i'm up to more frequently and
you know let's see all the manga that i buy
and what i get up to on the weekends then make
sure you check out my twitter which i will leave
obviously down in the description below as well
or here somewhere on screen obviously i can't
thank you all enough for the support that i've
been getting with my chainsaw man video uh like
the full story that i uploaded it's been exploding
before the freaking trailer is even released which
is actually mental to me i can't like i can't
actually believe how many people have got into the
series before the freaking trailers even come out
or before the animes had like any solid trailer
actually come out we've only had that first one
and it's not really like giving us too much of
a look into what's actually there there's just a
lot of explosions like and only if you've read the
story you kind of know what's to come and what's
about to hit like happen from those little scenes
and so i'm super excited to see you know what this
final trailer brings us and i'm pretty sure it's
on the seventh so in like six or five days from
now it'll be out yeah anyway obviously enough of
that that's gonna be old by the time this video
is two months old yeah anyway i'll catch you
all in a bit for now it's been a professional
degenerate diavolo and i'll see you later bye